[Laughter]
hey you guys what's going on it's friday
night i'm sitting here singing a pookie
yeah she's a pookie star yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we have i i don't go out yeah we're
gonna go out after the show so we're
gonna try and not drink too much because
we don't actually have technically we
don't have to leave for like three hours
but
you know how i do i'm just kind of stuff
she gotta do still i mean not really i
just this isn't the shirt i'm wearing i
gotta change my shirt put my course on
and put my shoes on but other than that
i'm pretty much ready because you know
how it's like i like to have at least
like two or three hours to get ready
yeah so this whole like
rushing to get ready kind of [ __ ] i just
i'm not about it let's see who's here
i started getting ready like a little
bit before four o'clock and i was still
not done zach's here
connor vox lawn tammy
howdy what's up everybody
okay we got
khan's ready for some cyber rage
what's that
khan's ready for some cyber rage is he
cause you because you were displaying
cyber rage on wednesday night yeah okay
yeah i might i might do something you
might do something i might do something
i mean yeah because you got super
inaugurated like really early and yeah
like very shouty yeah well you gotta you
know
you gotta get me off you gotta be
shouting you gotta
i have to i have to start stumbling into
uh some kind of a topic to where it'll
set me off you know
yeah obviously yeah that's that's how it
works
it's not the show is not scripted the
show is all out clearly
this is it's reality
reality is no no by tom i got my own
version of it but we all each one of us
has their own version of reality but you
can be in your own dream world until my
reality starts crashing in kind of like
back in the day
with mustache man and the [ __ ]
soldiers the germans of the bet cross
they'd get on tv and they'd lie every
day about how they were winning the war
until that one day those russian tanks
rolled in on berlin and they couldn't
lie anymore that's what it's like khan
that khan knows what i'm talking about
that's what it's like you can lie lie
and lie until reality starts crashing
down on your ass until tom comes in with
this little with his little underwear on
in his heart wig
dancing wig underwear he comes in like
donkey kong like honky kong hockey car
and he just destroys everyone else's
paradigms yeah no there's all there is
there's these individual realities and
then there's the ultimate reality and
you you want me to get really meta that
is actually your reality which nobody
else uh
ascribes to they are of course they know
i'm not alone
[Laughter]
i let her i just let her say what she
wants to say oh well thank you i
appreciate that very much
the little woman
everything that exists exists because i
allow it to exist it's like that it's
like galacticus
you heard it here it's like it's like
galactus yeah
it's not loud we only live in it i'm
allowing it to exist somebody commented
on that show uh drunk tom is a very
strange person
and i was like you don't know the half
of it
uh zach says love the eye makeup jenny
thank you uh very black swanish yeah i
was just kind of like
like i said i'm glad i didn't [ __ ]
mess it up isaac you know because like i
said i i was like well i don't want to
rush so i'm going to start getting ready
at like quarter to four
and then i'm like [ __ ] around i do my
hair and the makeup and everything like
that and then before i realized it was
like 5 30 i'm like and i wasn't even
but at least i got while i was waiting
for the for the show to come on like in
the last 15 minutes i did my nails
because i was like i didn't even have
time to do my nails god damn it because
they looked all [ __ ] raggedy and [ __ ]
but look
look how fantastic
i just got these it's like it's it's
super hard to put them on you just like
stick them on with glue
i have these ones and i have some that
are like black and red
so we'll see how long they last
tonight
then if they snap off but i have extra
ones and glue and i'll take it with me
in case they snap off i'll just like put
them back on and i have black polish
underneath so i don't think anyone's
gonna notice
but i'll notice i like them to look nice
you know exactly saying that i am the
dad from uh from every haunting episode
that does not believe the house is on
yeah pretty much no actually no
no i would believe the house is haunted
well yeah but he i think he means that
like in a more general sense
not that specific uh scenario yeah you
know what i mean
yeah you like [ __ ] crushing
everything what's that
hopefully it's going to be fun out
tonight well
we're going to go tonight because um
dimitri is djing
i guess he's out on the patio i think
you know because it's venue 13 fridays
at mannequins
and dimitri is djing out on the patio
and we haven't seen demetrius jen for a
really long time and i felt really bad
we haven't seen them for probably like
two months at least yeah
i think the last time we saw them was
kind of we'll take pictures
if we remember yeah like i said i'm
going to try not to bring your phone
i always bring my phone okay you can
take pictures with your phone huh yeah
yeah
yes it's the 21st century you can take
pictures
[Laughter]
being a smart ass is in my dna
i come from a long line of smart asses
i can't help it
and honestly my first my first go-to is
always smart ass con it's just in our
minds if i'm sober then sometimes i can
bite down on it because i was like maybe
i shouldn't like say that like sarcastic
thing but you can bet that i'm thinking
it see i gotta do two hours
at least two hours of [ __ ] sidetrack
with only two drinks
that's rough
that's [ __ ] rough your life is so
difficult tom
because i gotta
i gotta i gotta drive the club i can't
get loaded yeah so you know well and i
don't really want to get [ __ ] up
because last time because we have gone
out on friday night before like after
the um you know after the show
uh i think the last time we did that i
did actually drink more than i intended
to on the show but then i one i don't
have to drive and two when i got there i
had one drink and then the rest of the
night i just drank water so i didn't get
like drunker you know what i mean so i
ended up having like a good time
because i was just kind of like yeah i
don't need anymore and i said to anna
the bartender i was just kind of like
yeah i drank before i got here so i
think this is gonna be it
khan said he was researching the other
day the first emperor's tomb in china
that'd be a good show i don't remember
if you've done it yet dude we already
talked about it no we uh i put it in the
poll put it on the pole that went up if
you're on patreon the poll went up at 10
a.m this morning eastern standard time
and that was on there i just put john
wilkes booth on there because we were
watching like old unsolved mysteries
last night because that's kind of just
like a relaxing thing to put on there
and they have like all of them on to be
yeah and so we put one on and they had
the one about john wilkes booth you know
like the whole conspiracy theory about
like the guy that they killed in 1865
wasn't really john wilkes booth like
supposedly it was some other dude and
like they were talking about that so i
was like oh that might be a good show
too i don't know like what
revelations have come out since then
because this show was like from the
[ __ ] 90s or something like i think it
was from 96 or 97. so i don't know
what's come out yeah grandpa's asked me
for he's got he's got a couple of topics
he he wants to know about the ladies of
steve's basement smush room this
mushroom and
how russian troops compare with u.s
troops
best movie of gunfights of all times and
how to make god friends if you're a
normal oh all right those are good
topics let me start off oh david's here
sarcasm 101 yeah that's just kind of
like
like i said sarcasm is my default
setting i don't always
make smart ass comments because
sometimes i'm like well maybe it's not
because it would sound mean but i'm
always thinking them
do you want me to answer this question
yeah okay i just wanted to like get in
there and say something before you went
off on the basement two hour rant okay
the basement thing
all right back in high school you see
this mushroom this [ __ ] must have been
legendary because grandparents knew
about it
i think everybody in the damn drama
[ __ ] program knew about it probably
steve steve was my best friend and he he
was [ __ ] wild okay he ended up being
the [ __ ] going to university for
[ __ ] genetic science and [ __ ] he met
at one time he's a cool dude yeah he's a
genius okay
and uh
i just amused the hell out of him i'm
not a genius but he just [ __ ] if i
he's [ __ ] loved me [ __ ] the [ __ ]
i'd come up with we both kind of had
very similar personalities and there was
this synergy we'd kind of feed off each
other and push each other into [ __ ]
trouble all right it was one of those
kind of things
well
his uh step dad
worked for ford
and they had a house there was in
[ __ ] trenton
and uh
he had a bedroom upstairs but downstairs
they had a basement these michigan
houses all have basements
and uh he had permission from his step
dad to [ __ ] build a like a [ __ ]
lounge he called it a lounge down there
and he [ __ ] i remember when they were
doing it he went out there and [ __ ]
put the lumber and [ __ ] insulated it
and everything pretty much insulated
and um put doors in it in the closet
furniture
well that [ __ ] became like the center
for um listening to pink floyd and
[ __ ] other people's daughters that's
really what that was about man well i
mean technically every woman is
someone's dog that's what i'm saying
these are high school girls you know we
were in high school yeah so they were
still daughters you
know
it was [ __ ] wild man and uh
just they're all good girls you know
[ __ ] middle-class girls and [ __ ]
nice they were awesome and some of them
ended up [ __ ] being famous and [ __ ]
and uh cute from the drama program most
of them
and uh i name i'm not gonna name any
names man you know you know who they
were
you have before though yeah i had before
but i don't know why you're about to
shout out
somebody's something a lot of them are
just married and gone and you know
[ __ ] people's moms now
and it was well yeah and that's high
school it's like i don't even remember
most of the [ __ ] that i did in high
school to be honest it was a long time
ago
it was [ __ ] wild man
um
and just
patrick el nirmi and just the [ __ ]
crowd that was hanging out the time but
anyway
that's that's what he's talking about
i'm not going to get into detail my
imagination's running wild
i think if only if i knew what i knew
now i was [ __ ] everybody who says
that yeah everybody says that okay
except me i don't give a [ __ ] all right
how the russian troops compare with us
troops all right
you have to put this within time within
a time zone
okay so you have to talk about right now
all right
um the state of readiness in the u.s
army and in the armed forces in general
is [ __ ] piss-poor
the qualities pissed poor
it's worse than a [ __ ] drafty army
it's worse
because when you're drafting soldiers at
least you can get
people of good quality who's joining now
or just the bottom of the barrel uh and
b being a uh you know [ __ ] veteran
of 101st you know from good units first
327 recon [ __ ] alpha company first
three two seven
charlie company first 506 we were in
korea up in [ __ ] cap greaves i was in
good airborne infantry units
i still got friends that you know are
associated some of them are freshly out
but they ended up being [ __ ]
first sergeants as sergeant majors some
of them and um
you know the some of them ended up going
into the going green to gold and become
a commissioned officer
mark tremet trapansky i went to basic
with him he ended up being a [ __ ] um
armored officer when he went gold ended
up making captain
and then i still talk to him right now
he's telling me how [ __ ] up the
officer corps was he said the officer
corps second lieutenants were worse than
privates during the time that we were in
and and i was in when the army was at
its strongest in the [ __ ]
early early to mid 90s odd army was a
[ __ ] fantastic army probably never
been an army that good
but then it just got beaten to death in
[ __ ] iraq and afghanistan for [ __ ]
decades of that it's just like it's it's
not the same military
the civilians don't know that but it
isn't it's just not the same military
it's it's trash
it's a
basically kind of like welfare
and uh
kind of like a jobs program
and uh the
the problem is the officer corps officer
corps is just [ __ ] up
starting well for the generals it's just
political generals
they're civilians they don't need to be
there most of them
i mean people don't realize that you can
just walk in and be a general you don't
go to basic or anything
they just do these little courses
they'll give you a little green suit you
can put little things on them
yeah ranger tabs and [ __ ] but it's all
corrupt they'll just put pin that on
people it's super super easy
so you put those dudes in charge and
they're basically not even fit to
[ __ ] run a corporation like
mcdonald's
you know they're not military men or
military women either this there were
good military women they're not even
that they're just political people
so it's decimated uh it can't go to
combat that's why people are saying oh
we're gonna go fight russia and this and
that no no the pentagon knows that it
sucks it will not send that it will not
send that army into the field not in any
numbers
now they got some special operations
guys
there and um i think part of the 82nd is
there probably part of the 101st is
there but that's the cream of the crop
there's not enough for those guys
in a [ __ ]
in a slam fest with the [ __ ] russians
they'd be wiped out in about three
months they wouldn't last
uh they'd just be outnumbered
um
and they wouldn't get this air support
that you're used to all this [ __ ] air
support [ __ ] that would dry up quick
the um now the the russians the way they
work
is very different from the us army a lot
different
they basically have four different
armies
the first army is a draftee army
and that's not even really an army
the second one is a professional army
that manages the draftees
and then there's an intelligence agency
which is up there and kind of the the
job the intelligence agencies is to
intimidate
the professional generals to keep them
from [ __ ] causing trouble
and then there's things called
thieves or
their organized crime that's kind of
merged in with the intelligence agencies
and that happened back in the soviet era
when there was a big gulag system
communists put a lot of people in gulags
a friend of the communists is a thief
or organized crimes organized criminals
that fit in real well with communists
because they both can't stand the
concept of [ __ ] private property
so to steal is to do is to be is is to
do good in a certain way
so
a long time ago this is
world war pre-world war ii bolshevik era
the the the soviet
or russian intelligence agencies and
organized crime merged but that happened
here too all right
it even happened in japan with the black
dragon society not the one with [ __ ]
what's his name another black dragon
so the way they work is this
and they also have a mercenary army it's
called wagner group
what they do is is they just send their
[ __ ]
drafty army out in tanks and armored
vehicles they just line them up and just
point them towards the enemy behind him
as a professional army watching them
and
they let him make enemy contact and then
they stop basically there and then
they'll surround it kind of in a pocket
and then the professionals move in and
tell them to tighten it down and they
make these little miniature sieges it's
called
they make they're called cauldrons and
it's it's an old way of doing things
goes back to the napoleonic wars wars of
maneuvers
and and that's how they do it and then
if they get into trouble
they'll bring in airborne troops or
they'll bring in wagner group which is
like you know to take care of these
cauldrons
they'll use their power too
but soviets don't the russians don't
like to use air power that much
uh it's just not really that part of
their doctrine they don't it's expensive
it's cheaper just to throw
just to throw um
troops at it
because they don't
see those troops the same way we would
if you got to be drafted then they
consider then the professional military
considers you a [ __ ]
throwing drafted troops at the enemies
kind of like our version of like
throwing missiles at something or
throwing a
throwing a grenade you know they don't
really care if those guys get killed
now some of those draftees end up being
pretty good they like it and then
they'll ask them to come into a
professional army where they become ncos
and make them airborne troops and stuff
but
in general if you had to be drafted they
already hate you okay you should have
joined that's the way they think
okay so
they look at what's happening now and
say well where was all the shock and awe
where was all the [ __ ] air strikes
and everything russians don't do that
they'll get in there use wars and
maneuver
uh they incarnate the enemy they start
launching sieges and then they negotiate
during all the sieges they try to get
people to flip
they try to get people to surrender they
try to do things you know they actually
actual general ship
so warfare is part of their negotiation
the us armed forces is actually a lot a
lot worse
we just come in and just [ __ ] bomb
everything flat just kill every [ __ ]
body
and then we just walk the troops in
because there's no enemy anymore
and then we sit there and run patrols
and have like law enforcement [ __ ] going
on for 10 15 years
we get tired and leave nothing
accomplished
that's the pattern not the russians the
russians get in there
beat your ass
kick you out of your own country or take
a country from you saying that you don't
belong here
move you somewhere else or disappear you
and then they live in there in that land
and then 30 years later it's forgotten
like it didn't even happen because
they'll just rewrite history
you know that actually works they'll
salt the ground with your ass
they don't care
you can't really negotiate with them if
if they come out and say look this is
going to happen and you go now we're not
going to do that then they just they'll
fight it out with you
you know
and uh
they mean it they don't bluff
they don't bluff
they're going to win that [ __ ] too they
are winning that just that they're not
saying it on the news they're scared to
tell you that
granthars also asks uh a long time ago
what is the
best
movie gunfight
best movie gunfight the one from heat
was quite good yeah yeah
it was okay
um
yeah i'm trying to think it's like
there's a lot of them other than heat
nothing is really like springing to mind
a lot of the stuff that actually was
real um
real realistic was stuff that you saw in
band of brothers that that's what it was
what it's really like abandoned brothers
and some of it from like saving private
ryan some of that stuff was pretty
accurate to what they kind of look like
they're not very epic
in reality well yeah that's what i mean
that's why they always
yeah that's why i i always kind of like
well you have to make things like sort
of realistic in a movie like to suspend
your disbelief but
if you make stuff like real yeah
sometimes it doesn't like
it's not really all that dramatic i mean
it feels epic when you're getting shot
at and [ __ ] and [ __ ] well
but if you were to actually you can see
videos of it you can see videos of stuff
happening one of the most epic [ __ ]
gun fights i ever saw was a security
camera a two mexican cartel shooting it
out outside of a damn
um
uh pack a sack or a [ __ ]
quick store like a convenience store and
they [ __ ] each other up and it was a
professional ambush vehicle vehicle
ambush
and they shoot it out both sides
semi-auto weapons i think one of them
might have a full auto weapon the guys
in the in the vehicle and then once they
gun those guys down they did a [ __ ]
they did what was called a sweep they
sent a sweep team in to double tap all
the [ __ ] guys to make sure they were
dead and then they leave which that's
that's military training to make sure
nobody nobody lives
zach says for me the best one was the
one at the end of skyfall at the mansion
with the helicopter yeah that was pretty
good yeah actually i really like skyfall
actually yes um mr88 says best movie
gunfight atop blonde
hands down we haven't seen that movie
yet but you know what's weird
um
we just saw it mentioned thank you trey
patreon won't let me of my support past
five dollars so here's enough to make it
20 for april thanks guys thank you so
much trey yeah i know you yeah you
messaged me uh a couple days ago that
you were having trouble with patreon
um
it's interesting that you mentioned
atomic blonde because i was just
watching if any of you guys have shutter
they have a series on there called
cursed films
and they put up one there's one season
already and then the second season is
going now and now they have like three
um episodes up so the episode that they
just put up yesterday was about the um
andre tarkovsky movie stalker
and
uh so it was kind of about like all the
[ __ ] that happened around that shoot
and they mentioned in that documentary
that
the movie atomic blonde had been playing
the movie stalker like in the background
like in a few of the scenes like during
some of the fight scenes which i
actually didn't realize it's weird
because i remember seeing the trailers
for that and i was like man that looks
kick-ass but then like for whatever
reason we never just never got around to
like watching it so i don't know it's
like it seems like the universe is
telling me that i need to watch it
because i've had like two or three
people mention it to me recently so oh
and by the way has anybody seen the
north man yet because
i want to see that [ __ ] i know it just
started
um and i'm thinking about even like
driving to the theater to see it because
i heard it's like metal as [ __ ]
mr 88 says the reason why the u.s army's
quality is so poor is because services
based upon self-sacrifice and but their
recruitment policies is about
self-interest exactly right exactly
that's part of it another part of it is
that amer you have to look at the
recruitment numbers right now and if you
go to look at the recruitment numbers
pops talked about that the other day
whose ex-special forces guys says
they're classified which means that
they're [ __ ] pissed poor and then
they put out retention retention they're
losing everybody
when they sent those dudes to [ __ ]
poland
one third of the [ __ ] ncos [ __ ]
and one-third of the officers resigned
yeah that's bad side very very bad sign
and uh because the u.s is so polarized
who are you going to send into combat
democrats or deplorables because it
can't be both at the same time
and they kicked out anybody that they
said was a trump supporter
so that means that no republicans are
joining and the backbone of the [ __ ]
fighting forces were all southern
republicans so nope that's it that's the
end of that army so so who were they
recruited well according to the
according to the [ __ ]
recruitment
ads that they put out people from the
lgbt community up north
and not enough but there's not enough of
those to make an army
so that was just not gonna work
so
it's just like everything else
empires have an expiration date
if you look at history once it gets this
bad there's no example of it ever
reversing and reversing itself and
getting better
this is part of the [ __ ] reproductive
cycle of nations
it's like cellular mitosis cells divide
and that's what's going to happen
we just don't it just it's hard to
predict how long it takes
hopefully it will be peaceful probably
will be because there won't be a
centralized army to do anything and
besides they couldn't soviet union
couldn't even hold itself together using
a [ __ ] army
it just fell apart if they were to send
tanks out hey man go into the satellites
and tell them they can't leave
they just people we just would have
laughed at the tanks and it continued to
do what they want to do what are you
going to do
tanks can't keep can't change people's
minds
it's just
just
government is kind of a [ __ ] thing
that everybody has to agree to a tank
can't be everywhere at once people can't
be everywhere at once and you just
it just falls apart
so
new national identities are forming
nobody knows what'll happen
historically it's bad we'll see
we'll see i don't know
granters also asked best way to befriend
a goth if you're a normie
you have to meet him outside the scene
can't meet him in a club
yeah i come well i mean it's not
impossible for that to happen but a
certain kind of character
but usually yeah
if you're a goth person and you're in a
goth club or you're at a goth night or
something and some normal person like
approaches you
you're automatically wary because like
what the [ __ ] does this person want from
me yeah you know what i mean but it
could happen i mean there was a dude
[ __ ] big yeah
that's what i was thinking big bill's
just this huge six foot two
kind of corporate
hispanic guy who's you know he's cuban
and
who just had a way with women and he was
a legal drug dealer he worked for those
drug companies he sold drugs to
hospitals
and uh
he was going out with [ __ ] um sonya
for a while
and he liked goth girls and he would
just come in and [ __ ]
normal
he was yuppie
yeah he was a yuppie but he was very
cool
yeah he was very cool that's what i mean
it's like it's kind of like the thing
about him is that
you know yeah they're like yuppie dudes
and they like goth girls and blah blah
blah but you can't like make a thing
about it no he didn't make a thing about
it he was just like being a normal
person
um you know if you come up to a person
and be like ooh your hair is so ooh and
blah blah and you do when you like fawn
over the
you know all over the look then there
then immediately we're gonna be like on
our guard like do you think i'm like a
costumed like disney character or some
[ __ ] like that but if you just act like
a normal person
bill got in bill got in because he he
took the time to hang out with goth guys
he'd go up [ __ ] buy a round of drinks
and start talking and he wasn't an
[ __ ] he was cool he would talk about
stuff that was outside the just normal
[ __ ] yeah and he knew music and stuff
and uh
he done he did his time at the club and
he made a lot of friends
because he got he got the bro okay you
know what i mean you got the okay the
broke the brokay
[Laughter]
that was part of we just coined that
once you get the broke
then uh but
that was like a lot of that had to do
with the way bill looked
um he was a big guy he looked like your
boss
all right he's kind of authoritative but
he wasn't but he wasn't a he wasn't a
dick he was very very alpha
well he was just very personable yeah
right yeah a [ __ ] very much kind of
like a uh
a gregarious kind of uh yeah he's still
a lot he's still around it's like yeah
we're talking about it i just haven't
seen him at all we haven't seen him like
yeah yeah there's a hey another good
round of brown and drinks to the boys
here yeah dude did you see that oh man
you know he was just one of those he's
just one of those guys
and uh but it to him it was just
normal he would bring some of his
friends over and they would flop and he
would laugh at them flopping he's like
they don't understand this place
you know they don't understand this
place
yeah that happened a few times yeah i
think that he did that just because he
thought it was funny yeah like to bring
yeah he didn't like people that one girl
you don't like yeah because i remember
him doing that because everyone was fine
with bill
um because like i said even though he
totally looked like a yuppie yeah um
he was awesome he's like he's a cool
dude yeah and but he would bring these
other people see that's what that's what
it's not so much that gots don't like
normies they don't like people that make
a big thing about it or
try to draw attention to themselves or
just kind of like ooh look how weird
like act like all [ __ ] touristy yeah
like weird about it like just be normal
yeah just like i don't want to come in
and start acting real touristy and they
try to act up to get to get your
attention yeah yeah yeah and try to play
some kind of a role to get your
attention because they can't be who they
are because there's not much to him
there was something to bill so he didn't
have he had he was confident that's what
i mean he didn't have to like be like he
didn't have to like come in the door and
be like look at me you know what i mean
but bill could go to that biker bar and
[ __ ] get ahead there you know what i
mean yeah
he's that he's that kind of guy
he come in here yuppy as [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] rolex and all this [ __ ]
let me get the drinks for these men
right here that's a fantastic motorcycle
where how would you he he'd just get it
he was good about asking questions and
being interested and getting to know you
that way yeah and just like that like i
said he didn't he was just a person he
didn't he doesn't make like a thing
about it he had real good leadership
skills and one of the and this is
something that grabters probably knows
you know this comes from military he was
a football player he he knew how to do
it he's one of those he was like a
football quarterback
his strength was he could come into a
[ __ ] place eye everybody up
understand the hierarchy and then make
you feel important that's what [ __ ]
he did he'd come in and make everybody
feel important
but not by kissing ass just by showing
respect and treat you know what i mean
just that that was that's a good way
most leaders do that most leaders make
other people feel important
well honestly it's not even leaders it's
just people that are well liked yeah
yeah
um nobody likes somebody that makes
everything all about them right you know
what i mean um you know if you meet
somebody and they're just all like look
how awesome i am it's like nobody wants
to hang out with that person
um if you're a person that's genuinely
interested in other people
um you know and there's like a back and
forth like hey what do you do man that's
cool it's like i do this and you're like
man that's cool um you know what i mean
that's kind of like way more
appealing
no matter what you look like than
somebody that just makes everything all
about them i think that's why you know
like i said in goth clubs the
normally like the
kind of normie people that come in there
we don't like them not because they look
that way
but because they
seem like they're really insecure and so
they have to like
compensate for that by by drawing
attention to themselves or they come in
they think you're right at disneyland
they want to take a picture of you and
them so they can put it on their social
media
and you're like no no no like look at me
hanging out with the freaks yeah yeah
yeah it's nice it's that kind of
so it's like do i look like the elephant
man yeah is that like what you're out
here like [ __ ] off with that oh we've
had this look at this oh my god we've
had this happen so many times thank you
zach it's my understanding that a lot of
guys my age are into goth girls because
of the hex girls from that animated
scooby-doo movie from the 90s i don't
know i didn't see that but
it may be and it's it's weird because
it's a fetish but i guess you can't get
too mad about it because pretty much
everything is a fetish to somebody
so
as you know i can't get too mad about it
but
i can get mad about it
like when i'm out and about and dudes
think that because you look like that
um then that means that you're like open
for anything ooh this girl must be like
really [ __ ]
into some freaky [ __ ] i'm into that so
they see you as just like a fetish
rather than like a person which again
problematic
but
before i get off
what i wanted to do is before i just
totally forget about this
i wanted to throw in something
on the question granters
asked
back on the russia thing they're not
trying to take that country what they're
doing is they're building a [ __ ] dmz
there a buffer zone
in the eastern half
which is the same thing that we have in
south korea
we had that in [ __ ]
vietnam too for a while between north
and north and south vietnam these dmz
buffer zones
that bumpers buffer zone if you look at
the ethnic makeup that's all ethnic
russians right there on that [ __ ]
eastern one quarter
and that's what they're doing they're
gonna make it and they're already flying
[ __ ] russian flags there they're
trying to go back to [ __ ] mother
russia
it's very ethnic based they're not
telling you everything about what's
happening they got what they wanted
it will not be over for a long time
it'll be kind of like korea
and korea's been going on since the 50s
the russians and [ __ ] the russians
are great at stalling for time and
wearing the enemy out
so what they'll do is
they'll have a dmz set up there and they
will drain they will do everything they
can to drain nato of its funds
by trying to fortify their side of
[ __ ] the other side the western side
of uh of ukraine they know how to play
this game they wrote the book on that
game going all the way back to the 50s
the russians are real good at this [ __ ]
and we aren't we don't have any staying
power wrong kind of government
wrong kind of people
and russians man they're
you don't you can't underestimate them
they're smart
they got [ __ ] a lot of pride they've
been beat up for [ __ ] thousands of
years
they got a lot of [ __ ] to prove
and uh and they're sick of us they're
sick of us talking about them like
they're a bunch of [ __ ] gangsters and
criminals and all they they they they
hear what we're saying about them or
what our media is saying about them so
they just go okay they hate us then
we're gonna [ __ ] break it off what
they're gonna do is they're gonna invest
everything in china and india
and uh they're gonna print their own
money and have their own news
and they're just going to be separatists
they don't need us
they got a big [ __ ] country
and i guarantee you'll start doing
better and people will immigrate there
but it'll be decades you know 20 years
murder hornet says goth with tennis
shoes honestly i'm not going to hate on
anybody well okay maybe a little bit for
wearing tennis shoes but
if i know you and you're coming to the
club and you just want to dance your ass
off and you're like look i've worn
uncomfortable shoes like for a long time
and i'm just gonna like wear tennis
shoes so i can dance for hours then
that's that's fine that's fine like i
said it's not so much what they dress
like it's what they act like
that
kind of is is what the whole thing is
about
you know
they're talking about
uh
some septic tank kind of [ __ ] we talked
about that [ __ ] didn't we like the
[ __ ]
uh that the homeowners insurance said
that they were going to like dump us
yeah you mentioned that on
the last show
yeah i was looking at this company
that's uh has uh solar panels they'd fix
our roof to put the solar panel things
on well like i said you should look into
that because you can get all kinds of
[ __ ] tax breaks the more i'm looking
at it though
if there's any problems with those
things and
then you have to spend a lot of money to
have that [ __ ] repaired and the
insurance company is going to really
iffy about whether or not they will let
you keep that for because they want
replacement every 10 years
it
it might be better just to [ __ ]
replace the roof 15 grand
jesus christ 15 grand
but the um
um
the what you call it the uh we can get
that folded into the mortgage the
mortgage company can help us with that
so it'll only make a difference of maybe
a couple hundred
a hundred or so and the next year we're
going to save 300 a month in taxes
so it'll it'll be a wash
i guess that's because we we have to
replace that thing every [ __ ] 10
years anyway
yeah i know but it's just kind of like
[ __ ] man
i told you until they changed the laws
they might change you know what i mean
that's just the way the laws are now i
know so
i owned a house back in the 90s and i
told myself never again never again
but
you know because that was a [ __ ]
nightmare
and that house that i owned was
like
significantly cheaper than this one of
course it was significantly this house
is going to go up i mean significantly
older too so it's like
you know we had a lot more i had like uh
had to have termites so we had like
termites the movie the the house was
actually like concrete block
but we did have termites like around
whoever owned the house previously this
is the house i owned in uh daytona
whoever owned the house previously had i
mean the house was tiny to start with
but they had built out the garage they
made that into a den
and they took um like the
the area that was like the screened in
porch and they made that another room
that was like another bedroom and it was
like off the kitchen
and so that back room was a later
edition the house was originally built
in 1958 but all the additions had been
added later
so the back room had a door to the
outside like to the backyard and it was
all concrete still but the frame around
the door to the backyard was wood
and termites had eaten it
so
we had to have termite guys come like
every we had a termite bond on the house
and that was like super sucky but i mean
we got lucky with that house i guess
like i said because i mean it was small
and it was old
um
and we had to pay a lot of [ __ ] money
to fix [ __ ] on it but it wasn't as bad
as it could have been you know what i
mean it was in okay shape
so
there were a few things we had to fix uh
when we got it inspected like some of
the electrical was [ __ ] up and we had
to get it rewired but other than that it
wasn't too bad yeah but hornet is just
saying i asked that navy seal his
opinion on ukraine he said it will stay
the way it is that the russia will hold
what they have and no more yeah i tell
them i agree if you look at the map they
got what they wanted they're just going
to keep that that's what they were
asking for
it's just going to be a hornet's nest
just like you
so they're going to call that a dmz just
like we have in south korea i was on
that [ __ ] and they're going to have
that demilitarized buffer zone right
there that's all they want they can't
take the whole thing and then they'd be
right up on nato again that would defeat
the purpose they want a [ __ ] warning
buffer
zone of at least a few miles
they got more than that so no they got
what they wanted it's going to hold it
just like that
so they never said it was a war this was
a special operation that
that qualifies
so they were truthful
they just lied to say they said they
weren't going to do it
and they went psych yes we're going to
do it you guys keep [ __ ] with us you
keep beating on somebody [ __ ]
eventually they'll strike back
you know
bundy data says is it good to get off
artificial sweeteners i've given up all
soda
you know i don't know well that splenda
is pretty good
um you know what's weird yeah
splenda is okay
but
i prefer
uh the taste of sweet and low that's
ridiculous really which is strange
because i don't like it
yeah well i splenda is okay but like i
said i was putting that in my coffee for
a while i'm like you know this tastes
kind of funny
so i ordered like a box of sweet and low
packets and started putting that my
coffee i'm like oh this is much better
so to me
because i don't put real
sugar in my coffee although if i did i
would get those little packets i used to
like those little packets of like brown
sugar you know what i mean that was like
you know on whatever unprocessed and
that was good i think it's called raw
sugar
that's good too but i was like well i
want something that's like zero calorie
and i was like ooh sweet and low that's
so like old school that's like some [ __ ]
like my grandma my mom had but when i
put that in the coffee i'm like oh that
tastes better splenda tastes kind of
weird to me i don't know why that is i
like it um and sweet and low tastes
better so i ordered it comes from
bananas doesn't it
what splenda yeah oh i don't know it's
it's sugar from fruit so it's like
fructose yeah i think it's from bananas
mostly i don't know it might be um
because they say oh it's made from real
sugar and i'm imagining probably it's
fruit juice maybe that's why it's like i
don't know it doesn't taste bad it just
tastes strange
i just think it tastes great
the bananas just [ __ ] has a lot of
have a lot of sugar in it
and that's where that's where they're
getting that
that sweetener
bananas yeah
maybe i don't know which that's fine but
like i said it doesn't taste like banana
no it doesn't yeah but to me it just
tastes it doesn't taste bad it just
doesn't taste like sugar to me it has
like an odd
taste to it which is not bad but not
ideal
so i got like some sweet and low like i
said like from the old digits like i
wonder if this is better i think i
bought some at dollar general just like
to see if it was better then i was like
oh i like this better and so then i
ordered like three big
boxes up from amazon like to put in the
coffee and i like it actually a lot
better
but
i don't know why that is it's probably
i'm sure sweet and low is like way worse
yeah bundy's saying that a [ __ ] roof
should last 15-20 years we know yeah but
you see we
are
all the insurance companies here are
either black water or [ __ ] owned by
black water or [ __ ] vanguard see
so they're trying to choke everybody
they want you to replace it at 10 years
that way they don't have any risk so
what kind of insurance company doesn't
take risk but that's kind of i want you
to take the risk that's the whole
business model of insurance like i said
it's ridiculous medical insurance is the
same way it's like well yeah we'll cover
you but you have to pay all the risk
like all the all of this [ __ ] you
have to pay a premium right then you
have to pay like up to a certain amount
like whatever it is even if you have
insurance through work which i used to i
don't need more i don't have insurance
at all right now but and i haven't for
like five years but i'm just hoping i
don't get sick if i do i'll probably
john wayne but yeah there's a new
netflix documentary but yeah what i was
gonna say was that
um
their whole thing is well they're trying
to minimize risk for them so they're
trying to like push off as much stuff
onto you as they can
um
the thing about health insurance was
just even when i had good health
insurance
i still had to pay
uh i still had to pay like out of my
paycheck every week
and if i went to the doctor it wasn't
free
you had to pay
a copay yeah
uh and you had to like if you did some
[ __ ] that was like
wasn't covered or whatever you had to
pay a lot and then you know what i mean
so it's like it didn't cover everything
so
to me it just seemed like they're just
trying to like [ __ ] take all your
[ __ ] money as well bunny sand the
water is boring so he's adding a lime
juice or tea bag like mint and just use
k sugar with a teaspoon no carbonation
yeah what i do and i do this
i go down to sam's and get those big old
things of lemon juice
you can get them also at like any a lot
of grocery stores like publix or
whatever get like a big old one quart
thing of lemon juice
i buy them in two packs which i think is
like five bucks as sam's so i got a
bunch of them they keep forever as long
as you don't open them they don't even
need to be refrigerated
yeah we just keep them in the pantry so
i'll get one of these big old [ __ ]
jars
put a bunch of ice from the ice maker
put the crystal clear
filtered water that comes out of my damn
refrigerator and then i'll grab out of
the refrigerator um
one of those lemon
things and squeeze a bunch of lemon
juice in there and then go over to the
coffee station and
put about three or four big old [ __ ]
heaping scoops of that
splenda in it
and stir it
and it dissolves instantly and it's
[ __ ] good man and it's
technically it says it's zero calorie
lemonade
[ __ ]
that's good it tastes good to be honest
yeah it could have 100 calories and i'd
still drink it
what'd you say yeah i mean to be honest
i'm not i like ice water
um i've drunk ice water my whole life
and i'm not bothered by it um i do like
to squeeze a little bit of lemon juice
into it but it doesn't need sugar or
nothing like that i've never even like
as a one of my nails snapped off i'm
trying to fix it but um even as a kid i
wasn't really into soda like i know that
people are like really into soda and
they're like oh they don't really like
to drink water and stuff but
i was never really into soda
ginger ale is okay root beer is okay but
i never like need it i don't need soda
it's not my favorite mr 88 says that um
splenda is sugar but with a molecule
removed and that that molecule is what
tells your body to identify it as food
so you never absorb the calories off of
it okay so it starts off with sugar it's
it's re processed sugar right yeah all
right yeah some reason i was thinking
that it came from bananas
and i mean we get those huge bags of
splenda from sam's yeah want another
drink yeah but like i said it's just
kind of like i don't know it's not like
i said it's not bad
it's just when i put it in my coffee it
just tastes
odd it tastes odd to me
and so i decided that i would try some
other
uh sugar options and honestly
i like sweet and low better which is
probably bad because i'm sure it's
probably like all chemicals but whatever
it's like i only drink like one cup of
coffee a day well
maybe two
i had a cup of coffee this morning and
then later i made an iced coffee with a
couple little sweet and low packets in
it but that's about it
so it's not like i'm drinking like a
[ __ ] done as [ __ ] it's okay i'll live
but yeah it's like it's weird because i
never really found water boring this is
hilarious but
when i was growing up
um
as both my parents worked so i spent a
lot of time at my grandmother's house
now my grandmother
uh
she did not she would not drink water
uh she would not drink fruit juice she
would not drink milk all she drank was
coke all the time
just like she would just drink [ __ ]
coca-cola and that was it and she used
to kind of well she didn't make fun of
me but she used to kind of like
low-key make fun of me because all i
wanted to drink ever was like ice water
because i wasn't really into soda i
don't know why i don't really like soda
all that much like i'll drink it but
it's not my favorite thing it's you know
so she used to laugh and she used to
tell me i would just get i was like look
i just want some ice water and she'd be
like you know that'll rust your pipes
that's what she used to say
and she used to drink just like coke
with every [ __ ] meal she never drank
water
all i drank when i was growing up was
water
milk
and sometimes juice if we had it we
didn't usually but if we had orange
juice or apple juice or grape juice i
would usually drink that but most of the
time i just drank ice water
and everybody else in my family was like
super like soda hounds and i just didn't
get it i didn't get it tom's like that
too he's just like ooh soda soda and i'm
just like
i don't know it just seems like a waste
of calories
i was like look if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna have that many calories i would
rather eat like a chocolate bar like
something like substantive i don't
really just want like a can of pepsi or
whatever it's not that good and honestly
even if it's really cold like if you get
a can of it or something like that it's
really only good
for the first few sips and then after
that it's like
like it goes kind of flat and so i'm
just i don't know i'm just not about it
i'm not a big soda fan which is probably
good
because i kind of feel like sodas
it's so much sugar and people don't
really think about how many calories
that has
and you know because you're not eating
it so you just kind of feel like oh well
it's just a drink so it can't be but
some of those sodas have like a [ __ ] ton
of calories in them
camp guy says with the k-cup machine i
now drink one drop of one cup of coffee
a day and that's it yeah i mean i have
in my office just right over there
i have a one cup
because that's all i need well like we
have a 12 cup uh pot downstairs
but
you know usually i get up and i'm just
like you know i usually get up um
several hours before he does
and so i'm just like well i'm just gonna
make one cup of coffee and drink it
and that's usually all i need sometimes
i'll have like an iced coffee later in
the day because tom will brew like a pot
and then he'll put it in like a big
pitcher and then put it in the fridge
and you know i'll make an iced coffee
out of that sometimes in the afternoons
but
in the morning i just have one
so
grampher says more topics worst
contribution from the south to society
[Laughter]
contribution to [ __ ] oh my gosh that
might be a long list nascar oh okay oh
wait no nascar racing or disney world
nascar racing no neither one
disney world is actually kind of fun
yeah no the word yeah disney when it
when it was
disney when it was good okay
disney's [ __ ] going sideways and the
last time i was there was [ __ ] 10
years ago
and that park was looking tired man
and cheap
um
[ __ ] if you want to come to orlando
to go to a [ __ ] amusement park don't
go to disney go to universal
it's a lot more fun
that harry potter ride the with the
[ __ ] broomsticks his virtual reality
that [ __ ] will blow you away i was
convinced i was riding on a [ __ ] brew
stick yeah he loved it
i was convinced i was proud of not on a
broomstick that was a good that was a
good ride and then you've never even
like you've never even read any of the
books or watching the movies
he doesn't know
i thought i was riding on a damn
broomstick man flying
wind blowing and everything it's 360
virtual reality and it's moving around
and the illusion of [ __ ] speed and
height is man yeah i bought into it and
jamie was next to me and the broomstick
next to me i'm yelling over and says man
this is awesome
it was as good as a real roller coaster
yeah but uh you do move you just don't
move that much and you're not going that
fast
well they're
they're blowing wind on you and missed
and they're [ __ ] with your mind
they're [ __ ] with your mind yeah
it's good then they have real um
real roller coasters too
they're as good as magic mountain out in
california
and um
if they got [ __ ] hot sc you girls
running around boobs and [ __ ] [ __ ] i
got it it's it's more adult it's a lot
more adult than [ __ ] disney disney
yeah i mean if you're it okay i will say
if you're into rides yeah universal is
way better yeah
if you want like a whole thing
because disney it's not just disney
world they also have epcot they also
have like a water park is the water park
still open i don't know i don't know but
they have like a bunch of they used to
have downtown disney i don't even know
if that's still around anymore but they
have like all these resorts and stuff
my sister
who lives in atlanta she usually comes
down for her vacation every year and
does like a week or you know week and a
half at disney
but
she goes to all the parks
and she stays at all the resorts and she
like um
makes uh reservations at like all the
restaurants and for all the stuff so
it's it's much more of an experience if
all you want is like one day and fun
rides and [ __ ] like that then yeah
universal is your go-to yeah cam guy
says we're going to universal yeah you
you you'll like universal i mean we
haven't been in a long time but it is
super fun yeah and and what they say
it's better than it's better now than it
was
how long ago was that that we went to
university a long time ago eight years
seven
six that was when we were hanging out
with minnie me yeah so that was probably
like 10 years ago was it that long ago
yeah
yeah we need to go back it was badass
back then
there's a lot of forced perspective
going on you have a hard time
understanding how big something really
is
uh especially in that [ __ ] harry
potter [ __ ] world
walking and well they built the whole
uh you know the whole diagon alley from
the books yeah so they even have like
all which like i said i admire their
commitment to
the whole theme of the ship yeah you're
waiting in line to go in it outside
looking at a mountain with this [ __ ]
castle on top of it
and it looks huge
but it's all forced perspective you're
going like wait a minute hold on
that's not possible that's not possible
for that to be there
that's what i really like about theme
parks is that they're that can't be
there yeah their whole thing is
engineered and all of these like artists
and stuff like that are working behind
the scenes to make sure that everything
seems as
because i like all of that like
immersive [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
back in the old days
um
i don't even think this was universal i
wanted to say maybe it was like old
school universal
there's used because disney used to also
have mgm studios which have the psycho
house and stuff like that but i don't
think that's there anymore
but they used to have that back to the
future ride
yeah which i don't think is there
anymore
but i went to that
and that [ __ ] was amazing because
as soon as you got into line
everybody was in character we are
pretending
that this is
like a scientific institute for time
travel
and everybody was like
buying into that illusion every single
thing that they had so it's like every
so much thought is like put into
making like immersing you in that
fantasy and i love that i just i think
that's so cool yeah there's really only
three things at disney the haunted house
the haunted mansion which is good
i love the haunted mansion pirates of
the caribbean
and uh well there's there's four things
a space mountain
and then uh the one with the uh
the the yeti ride what's it what the
[ __ ] oh they don't have that here do
they that's that's that's disney i was
like what do you have yeti that's
disneyland
i mean you might like they have splash
mountain no not splash mountain
which is uh
rare rabbit
the one that they had in the one that
they had in uh disneyland
in california was that's what i was
thinking of it was called um
it's the one where you're going up to a
snowy mountain and use the yetis up
there it's a rollercoaster the
matterhorn the matterhorn we don't have
that they don't have a matterhorn here
yeah
we have splashing three which like i
said spanish pounds okay splash mountain
is
like rare rabbit rare fox yeah all that
and that's fun yeah um although like i
said i don't even know if that do they
still have that it's been so long since
i've been together watch lifetime yeah
they have i think they still haven't
yeah thunder mountain railroad i always
kind of like that that's like a roller
coaster it's like a gold rush type of
theme flash mountain is about like the
log ride in in um
in um
magic mountain
yeah
yeah but uh no universal was blowing it
away
well universal and like i said it's been
at least 10 years since we've been there
yeah and it's better now i remember that
when we were there they had
what the [ __ ] did we go the harry potter
ride was like the easter it was new yeah
well the whole harry potter area yeah
was kick ass because
they made the whole thing look like the
books yeah like look here's the alley
with the and i think there's more of it
now in there yeah well i think they
expanded it out like look here's
hogwarts and like you go in there and do
the ride and then they had like a whole
street that was just like like i said
like diagon alley and it had like the
barn it had the candy shops that had all
the [ __ ] up candy that they had in the
books like you know stuff that tasted
like vomit and snot and [ __ ] like that
and uh so they had all of that
so like i said i i love the theming
um they had that roller coaster that was
was it the hulk
yeah the hulk was good yeah that was
like that was fun the hulk was about
kind of like uh i want to call it
try to put it in par with like magic
mountain out in california
it's kind of like uh the revolution
revolution i think it's called spirit of
76 the revolution kind of like the
revolution
it wasn't like colossus
that was the old wooden one
but it was kind of like the revolution
it was go it goes out throughout the
mountains it's kind of like imagine
you're in a jet fighter
going about 80
turning upside down and [ __ ] going
nap of the earth over these mountains
it was over mountains wouldn't it hills
going around hills i think they might
have been artificial
but there's definitely trees
yeah maybe you don't remember no yeah
that was a long time ago i remember
[ __ ] going straight down into those
damn trees and it felt like i was just
in a nosedive in a [ __ ] aircraft it
was good real good
yeah i mean
we do we should probably go back yeah it
costs about a hundred bucks but it's
very yeah it's really expensive yeah and
honestly like even when we went back
then it was kind of expensive yeah it
was us and minnie me and his girl choose
his girlfriend and another girl wouldn't
it or just his girl it was just
just liz
liz was his girlfriend though we didn't
know
well kind of he also had another
girlfriend yeah he had another
girlfriend and a chinese girl
and a chinese slave that was all kind of
there's some weird [ __ ] that's going on
yeah
i saw him picture something okay look
i'm gonna tell you guys something one of
those girls that we mentioned
if you saw her face she's like an
emperor from [ __ ] star wars
but she had a body of a [ __ ] like
penthouse pet
she looked like an old lady but she
wasn't old she just looked old
how old was she 30 well she was younger
than me she was yeah i think she was 30
something but she looked like she was
about 60.
i mean she was a couple years younger
when i was a [ __ ] trip at the time
yeah
and we didn't know it but [ __ ] mini
me was [ __ ] tearing it up
[ __ ] he he confided in me dude she's
got a nice body
like
like she does she goes yeah man i'm
[ __ ] i'm tearing it up i said dude
and he's like yeah well yeah he just put
a bag on her face
that's that's that's the way [ __ ]
minnie me was yeah she was like a butter
face she was like a butterface yeah but
i didn't even notice
that she had a figure
that's how [ __ ] kind of
homely she was we saw her recently
how long ago that was a while back
though it was a couple months was it
where the mannequins
you don't remember
she showed up to mannequins did she
really yeah
she looked exactly the same
i don't remember that yeah she looked
exactly the same how drunk was i almost
been pretty drunk i guess so yeah i mean
vaguely like now that you say it it was
the day that you took that picture i was
[ __ ] testing the [ __ ] out and you and
you and jen were sitting there sitting
there and i took a picture of you guys
and i said i'm like yeah both y'all
remember that [ __ ] [ __ ] oh i had the
red wig on yeah yeah oh okay
that's right oh yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
i remember she'll be exactly the same
she actually looked good she looks good
if she put a bag on her head
that's not nice tom yeah
she's crazy though that [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah
it's just she needs new teeth
she must have been a myth it had to be
meth maybe yeah
all her teeth missing
[Laughter]
she smiles a bunch of like a picket
fence
hopefully i hope she's not listening
camp guy says the hall of presidents uh
do they still have that attention no i
think it's gone it might be gone well i
don't know is it
i don't know i can't remember honestly
the only reason we ever used to go in
the hall of presidents was because we
always had to go to disney because like
i said you know my family was poor so we
if we went on vacation we're like hey
we're going to drive like 50 minutes and
go to disney
back in the 70s
and we would go and haul a president if
all the lines were too long and it was
too [ __ ] hot outside to like stand
outside so it's like let's go sit in
there in there oh [ __ ] for a little
while mr 88 says i grew up 10 minutes
from magic mountain 50 for summer pass
they've been there a hundred times you
remember that's not bad actually you
remember back in the day
back in the early eighties
near the chinese restaurant they had a
[ __ ] ride there called the magic
mountain
and it was like a fun house and you go
in there and they had a little [ __ ]
chinese things and little chinese cities
you looked at and he went into one thing
and it had a big old [ __ ] empty room
with a strobe light with a chinese
dragon going around the outside of it
and they had all these [ __ ] had a
hall of mirrors had a big old [ __ ]
buddha with his [ __ ] face talking to
you coming to the magic that [ __ ]
tripped me the [ __ ] out and then they
would have this weird magic [ __ ]
thing where the damn dragons coming at
you
they tore it down it's not a
it's been gone for a long time they
didn't think it was impressive enough
but i was a kid that [ __ ] kind of scared
me but it was like a fun house
you walked through it and it didn't
attract much attention a lot of people
didn't know it was there
it was next to the chinese restaurant
and magic mountain i loved it he might
remember that
i i mean i have to say
i don't even know like i said we haven't
been to disney in like a really long
time
but when i was a kid
that snow white ride was [ __ ] scary
as [ __ ] yeah the snow white ride was
scary and the peter pan one was kind of
scary too it was called the magic pagoda
isn't that isn't that what i called it
yeah yeah magic pagoda yeah we didn't
have that but i know yeah magic pagoda
i mean i'm super into
uh the history of like all the disney
rides like in orlando particularly i
have like several books about the
haunted mansion and like all the
sketches and all the artists that worked
on it i'm like really interested in that
and i'm always like really interested in
like the differences between the honda
mansion in california and the one in
florida so i think we did a show about
that did we not i think we did a dark
side of disney show and we talked about
the haunted mansion yeah grantham's in
their [ __ ] drinking game okay
more topics no do women appreciate man
boobs as much as men appreciate women
boobs i mean you probably know they
answered that no no no
it's hilarious to me i was just thinking
about this the other day because i was
uh i was thinking about i was writing a
review of a book
that had been written by a man
and um sometimes not always but
sometimes when a man is writing a female
character
it's a source of high hilarity for women
because it's like is that what we don't
think is that really like what we yeah
what they think we think like okay no
but yeah so
uh so it was very very funny so i kind
of feel like
men kind of like project there it's like
we love women boobs so obviously like
women also must be obsessed with their
own boobs yeah women don't give a [ __ ]
and it's not really i mean they're just
kind of like there and it's just kind of
like i have they're just kind of like in
the way you know i have had
when you say man boobs you're talking
about [ __ ] gynecomastia right you're
talking about well maybe not necessarily
maybe maybe just like man like chest
just has chests like chest like
testicles yeah they do they do
[ __ ] um
go down the biker bar and [ __ ] yeah
you have [ __ ] women during the day
going yeah
you know they're [ __ ] and going
show me yours i'll show you mine that
kind of [ __ ] you know but you know
they're drunk and they're they're having
fun
um had uh
had uh aurora
you were sitting right next to me aurora
[ __ ] put her fingers down in my
[ __ ] shirt and pulled it out and
[ __ ] looked at my chest
going yeah damn but you know but it's
not the same as a guy looking at a
woman's boobs but no women like good
chest on a guy yeah
i mean but the thing that we've talked
about this before women are a lot more
um complex yeah like they can appreciate
like hey that's a nice those are nice it
doesn't mean they got a nice chest
or something like that but
that doesn't mean that they're that they
like you or they're going to have sex
with you they're just kind of like oh
okay yeah that's the difference
yeah i kind of feel like dudes
in general yeah they'll be like hey that
girl's hot i'm gonna [ __ ] her i don't
care what she's like yeah she um women
are not so much
um sometimes they gotta like you first
yeah sometimes they'll be like oh that
dude's got a nice butt or something but
that's like as far as it'll go yeah you
should you she ain't going um yeah it's
like i'm not gonna have sex because i
don't know that dude it's like
he might be a [ __ ] creeper an [ __ ]
or something like that because yeah we
have much higher stances well okay look
let me [ __ ] let me [ __ ] throw some
let me throw some based science out here
on you people oh are you going to do
that this is going to be scientific okay
dr tom
this is true it's all backed up it's all
backed up by [ __ ] studies
men and women
have different reproductive strategies
but
women can't just [ __ ] the any old dude
coming along because he's got to stay
around to [ __ ] help that baby and to
take care of her during the pregnancy so
women have been selected to be
through through selective breeding
to choose the guys that will be with
them
through the pregnancy and the rearing of
the children
it helps if you look better but
number one priority is to be there
through the [ __ ] pregnancy
men evolved totally differently
men actually
evolved for polygamy for polygamy
to [ __ ] impregnate as many women as
possible
uh some of them you take care of them
some of them you don't
that seems to be
and most of the animal kingdom is like
that
so
and i think that actually
came from before
humans
that's a pre-human quality
animals are like that too well you can't
say that because like animal [ __ ] is
like all over the place yeah all over
the place but primates tend to be like
that
uh now generally yeah
usually there's a troop
um the alpha male
has access to pretty much all of the
females
but a lot of the beta males are getting
them too
but the prime females it might be three
or four of them the alpha's with them
you know although there may be betas and
[ __ ] sigmas [ __ ] sneaking some
spermatozoa and some children in there
too because a lot of people don't
realize it
apes cheat
yeah maybe it's been documented over and
over again where you got an basically
like an alpha female who's with an alpha
male but she's also screwing basically
she's like this dude i'm kind of like
this guy like this guy too so so
she gets pregnant by that one and the
alpha thinks it's his
there's a lot of that that
that's a lot of [ __ ]
right right it's like the prince factor
because that [ __ ] gorilla that got
the alpha female pregnant wasn't the big
[ __ ] he was the cute gracile
[ __ ] who was only like you know
[ __ ] 10
or 8 years old which that's kind of
thing that's mature for everything but
they were younger than the alpha but
she's like down with that too because he
was cute
so it's
humans like that
well like i said as we've mentioned on
the show before women are a lot more
complicated they're cop kid we're
complicated
um dudes are very simple generally not
always not everybody well the male
reproductive strategy is simple it's
very simple it's very simple but women
are kind of like we're a lot more i
don't want to say conniving because
that's that has a negative connotation
but we're a lot more practical in the
sense of uh you know what what is
everybody bringing to the table right
men have much less to lose in the animal
kingdom exactly
in the animal kingdom for us to knock
every [ __ ] up
i mean you all don't have to like spend
any effort you're just having a good
time exactly and then just like toodling
off into the sunset that was meanwhile
the rest of us are stuck here right
raising your in crotch fruit right in in
nature that was selected
but the thing is though is that in the
western world men are in a civilization
that has has a lot of laws
to where that could come back and bite
you in the ass
parental [ __ ] you know what i mean
[ __ ] you can get sued well yeah so
rightfully so so a lot of guys
i'd say all guys or any guy above 100 iq
is moderating his behavior
because he's punishing him
and the punishment
is going to be come at you [ __ ]
monetarily they're going to take your
money
you know i'm with this one but i knocked
up these two other ones and then the dna
test came back and now i gotta pay all
this money well so
that's what happens you [ __ ] around you
find out right so
just like everybody else on earth on one
hand you have the the forces of animal
nature but then on the other hand you
have the forces of [ __ ] mankind in
his laws
but and look i'm not saying the laws are
bad
you need laws to mitigate to keep
certain [ __ ] under control it has to be
reasonable if you ask me but
um
yeah you need to keep people in check
when you get down to it's other men
keeping these men in check too it's
really because that [ __ ] goes way back
parental [ __ ]
suits
go back even into what you what today
you would call the
patriarchy
because we still have court records
going back to the [ __ ] 13 1400s where
people were suing guys for knocking up
their daughters and they weren't married
to them
you know yeah so that goes way way back
well back in the old days i don't think
he can do it nowadays but back in the
old days if you promised somebody that
you were going to marry them like i'm
talking about like end of 19th century
early 20th century if you that was that
was like legally binding
you went you said i'm gonna marry this
person blah blah and then you went like
knocked up some other [ __ ] oh yeah you
can bet that that girl's family was
going to sue you
because you said you promised that you
were going to do that i mean
your word was
law essentially so a lot of people got
in trouble for doing that kind of [ __ ]
it comes to when it comes to males of
all species what you would call
promiscuity is selected but it's
mediated
by civilizations
now one of our listeners [ __ ] assad he
listens recorded a lot of times he's in
saudi arabia
he and i will get into [ __ ]
civilizational differences over [ __ ]
talking you know
like minds he he's becoming a doctor
right now he's a man of science
and um i'm down with that he's a man of
science
jenny is a woman of science yeah there
are there is
there are certain things to be said
about islamic culture
islamic culture is like we we have
something similar with the mormons
islamic culture does fit
human behavior where you have one men
and two or three females
but you have to look at the situation
where that philosophy came out of
kind of like war-torn areas where a lot
of guys were getting killed
so there weren't very many men
and
you're coming from a mindset where
you're not seeing women as like full
human beings also well i don't know if
i'd say that i think that's a side thing
the main thing i think the main force
that was happening
is that
in that environment in the time when
those rules were being written there
weren't very many alpha males or
weren't very many males that were
marriage
able or in other words able to be
married
and if you look at [ __ ] the data that
comes out of the internet
most women of breeding age are all
chasing that same top 20 percent of the
males
and i think that's kind of where this
came from
it doesn't have anything to do with
older women
it has to do with women of young women
of breeding age
all wanting that same top 20 percent out
of the percentile out of the male
population the ones that have the money
and the security and the status
and if they can't get that one some
other woman will will get that one and
she will be stuck with a beta or a or an
omega or something or never get married
so it's more in her
genetic advantage to go ahead and be in
a pluralistic marriage with sister wives
so she can have a child and her genes be
passed down
it was it came from a particular
situation
now here's the [ __ ] blowback from
that
you have a lot of incels
when you have a situation like that you
have a lot of guys that will never be
married because all the women are going
to the same those top 20 percent guys
well and let's
address the elephant in the room was
that a lot of the intel people are like
dicks that nobody wants to sleep with so
well women choose the top 20 they just
tend to but if you're gonna be like a
creepy weirdo then no one's gonna want
to sleep with you
so
that's not exactly what i was talking
about
it tends to be
when you have
women tend to want to chase that top 20
percentile of the males
if they can enter into a relationship
pluralistic relationships with them they
will
the problem is is that the other guys
never get mates
and what that does is that ends up
[ __ ] increasing their hostility and
their violence because their lives mean
nothing they're being weeded out of the
genetic process
they won't reproduce
so societies like that tend to have a
lot of violence towards women
because most of those guys will never
have one
it's not a good
strategy
i think statistically it's a better
strategy that one man should have one
wife
that way it kind of equalizes the
chances that everybody will be able to
get married
i think that's it's probably better the
thing about it more people will be able
to when you have more pluralistic
societies like western societies
us western europe things like that
um i think that's better overall because
most people
will find a mate somebody that is into
them for whatever
they're into
but i think it's a mistake to think that
the only way you can get women is to be
like top to play be the hottest or the
richest or blah blah blah
it's not always that
but
um
becoming resentful about oh i can't find
a woman because all the women like
like these rich dudes or so
that is not helping you that attitude is
absolutely not helping you
um and that is why people are avoiding
you actually
so
in this society
yeah that's what i'm yeah yeah but in
other societies where the women are all
marrying the same the same top level
guys
his problems do not equate to your
problems i lived in the middle east
i talked to guys that would never get
married egyptian guys they'd never be
they just don't have they just don't
have the they didn't have the incomes or
the family standings so they were just
being weeded out you know what i mean
and that that's a that's a rough that's
rough for a dude you know there's really
nothing wrong with the dude just that
all the women are married rich guys or
guys better than him
you know
so no it's he it makes it a lot
it it kind of opens up the market if one
person can only marry another one person
it makes more available people yeah
you know that that's i think in in in
general that's the way it should go in
the aggregate i think that's better
because like i said you're more likely
to find somebody that is more in line
with your
interests and your beliefs or whatever
so well you don't have one guy monopoly
metabolizing [ __ ] four females
but a lot of this has to do with of
breeding age
in other words when you're talking about
the [ __ ] animal kingdom
13 to [ __ ]
18
because you know in tribal societies
they're all pregnant by 18 they're
mothers by 18. yeah they're all
pedophiles
well everybody's getting well the father
they're all pregnant by 18 easily
pregnant by 16.
you know in in in most tribal societies
you got to go back
you know not even thousands hundreds of
years
not decades
in mississippi
back in the 50s chances are
if a girl was 17 she was already
pregnant
you know they were pregnant by that
because they were pregnant and married
the world was very different back then
well even and i i don't know if this was
really widespread but i mean
my mom married
my dad yeah when she when they were both
18 yeah
because she was pregnant with me
she had just graduated from they had
both graduated from high school
the june before and then i was born in
september
so you know there was that but you know
it's funny because my mom told me
much later hopefully she's not listening
to this she does sometimes i know
because she's like i don't see you that
much sometimes i listen to your show
just to hear your voice which is like
super sweet i love my mom
but
she told me
a few years ago i this honestly this had
never occurred to me i know that she had
me
uh when she was 18
and my dad was 18.
uh i didn't know the story behind it
i assumed i was accidental but i wasn't
like worried about it or anything like
that but
one day
several years ago
she pulled me aside like we were at a
picnic or something like that and she's
like
i know this is like kind of weird to say
but she's like i just wanted you to know
that you were not an accident
um
we got pregnant with you on purpose
because
uh your dad was gonna go into the army
or was gonna be like you know recruited
or whatever and we didn't want him to go
so
we decided that we were going to have a
baby
uh so that no one would be upset about
it so
that's kind of so my parents were 18
when they had me
um and it's hilarious that she kind of
like told me that because i was like
literally that never occurred to me that
you guys never wanted me because
my parents are kind of awesome and i was
just kind of like i never got that
feeling ever but i just so i thought
that was like very funny that she
thought that she was going to tell me
that like much later on
uh but you know
mr 88 says the general consensus among
scientists is the humans engage in the
middle ground dubbed serial monogamy
yeah that's uh basically what they do
most humans
it's not like we're
humans are kind of somewhere we're kind
of closer like bonobos than chimps
um
and you know bonobos will like [ __ ]
anything that moves
uh and chimps will like kill anything
that moves so it's kind of like a middle
ground in between
but yeah humans tend to do serial
monogamy like
you're with somebody you'll stay with
them for a long time you know you might
cheat on them or something but it's not
the super norm but then like you'll be
with them for a while you get sick of
them you moved on to the next one but
that's kind of like
uh what ends up happening with humans
it's not
you know
uh grant there's comes up with some more
oh wait john gore says online dating has
totally screwed the dating market
has it though i kind of feel like even
back in the old days
because i've read about some old true
crime cases about serial killers and
whatnot
and
there was still like there was a pretty
active community
around
personal ads
you know what i mean uh before there was
the internet everybody ran [ __ ] in the
newspapers
looking for
wives husbands blah blah blah
i have this many acres i have this much
money
i'm looking to get married hey come meet
me
uh and then like if you happen to answer
the ad of somebody like belle gunness
then she would hit you in the head with
a hammer and bury you in the [ __ ]
backyard so
read what cramter said about grantham
said more how steve was successful at
running a harem when most men fail at it
okay
all right did he really yeah yeah he did
he did
okay there's a couple different ways a
couple reasons why steve was able to run
a harem
all right
i'm gonna put him in this order
steve was good looking
and he could talk
okay those forget [ __ ] could
sing and [ __ ] carry uh
roll he he could he could do whole lead
roles and musicals
incredibly you know
[ __ ] he was good he was very talented
and he could play bass see like i like
it
he has star i like an artistic [ __ ] he
has star power
uh another thing about him is that he
wasn't trying to do anything bad to them
he liked him well that's a big plus yeah
he liked him because you would be amazed
at how uh
not common that is no his his attitude
was is that
that he loved all those girls and that
[ __ ] and that he was gonna do what he
could
to entertain them and to [ __ ]
and to make them feel special well
that's a good attitude but there was
like three or four of them but they all
knew but that's a good attitude to have
yeah yeah he liked to come at it yeah i
like this person genuinely yeah and i
want to make them happy yeah
right
yeah
so he he's not hard he wasn't means he
wasn't mean-spirited about any of that
well and he wasn't like conniving no
because i kind of feel like a lot of
dudes have this [ __ ] like but and
i'm not gonna say who's who it is right
but we've known a dude that is very um
you know gets around
and his whole strategy is
i'm gonna approach like the most
vulnerable
women like some women that have been
just gone through some [ __ ] or they've
just broken up with somebody or
something like that and i'm like that is
absolutely right yeah
here's the thing don't [ __ ] do that
steve did not pursue he didn't go after
all any of those women they came to him
he was too alpha for that
he was alpha as [ __ ]
he would just um
and i'd be there you know hanging out
with him and
one of the players would be chatting and
[ __ ] he'd look at me and she goes
she's [ __ ] sweet and i was like yeah
i know she's like and i said you can get
that because see i was
he we would always do that kind of [ __ ]
you could get that and he'd tell me
later on another you can get that and
[ __ ] and he's like yeah i don't know
but you know this and this is not let's
go don't worry about it don't worry
about it be all right and yeah it was
all right it was high school that was
another thing
everybody was young so there weren't
bills to pay
there wasn't a long term thing
you know what i mean it's not like there
was a careers involved in children and
families involved
so it was just at that particular time
you couldn't do that today
not unless you were
even rock stars probably couldn't pull
yeah they probably could pull it off
today
yeah they probably could but um depends
on the person depends on a person it's
just
uh
yeah you could do it today but in in the
younger crowd
i don't think older people put up with
it unless they're what you we what me
and jay would call swangers or fetish
people they could do it you know what i
mean me and jenny getting fetish offers
all the time but we don't want to [ __ ]
them
[ __ ] don't think there's anything wrong
with it there's nothing wrong with them
they're just [ __ ] as a [ __ ] had
i had [ __ ] and i appreciate the offer
little muslims shattering little
mussolini showed up [ __ ] laughing i'm
just kind of like they're with these
flattered tails but
and then his wife starts trying to mac
and then the girlfriend starts to back
and then he's getting mad and i says
dude you're getting fat are you how are
you gonna stay stay i love them though
yeah yeah they're good people they're
good people just fetish people you know
well and they're very just like open
about it like i said they've always had
a third you know you're dealing with um
you know she's bisexual yeah um and they
kind of have a they've been doing it for
years and years everybody knows
um
they don't really expect you
to
take them up on it no it's just it's
polite for them not to not it is but
they always like offer it is impolite
from their point of view it is impolite
for them not to [ __ ] offer because
like i said everybody
everybody because if you're not going to
have to because because they've been
around forever right and everybody knows
them so it's just kind of like
hey we need to like dude yeah so it's
just gonna happen because we've been to
their house before they had a birthday
party for me like a few years back like
they're like i said they're lovely
lovely people and they had a teenage
daughter who was just [ __ ] normal as
[ __ ] and embarrassed by all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] we thought that was so [ __ ]
funny
yeah they have a daughter that was
[ __ ] just i mean she's in her 20s now
she's their 20s now but back in those
days she was in her teens and she's like
this they are [ __ ] crazy
it's like so this is embarrassing
and it's like this this is what happens
well this is what happens to like gen x
parents yeah because like we're into all
like kind of freaky [ __ ] and then like
we have kids
and they're just like
okay y'all are like old what the [ __ ]
you ever seen that british series called
[ __ ] absolutely fabulous yeah it's
the [ __ ] chance i love that and that
daughter came out yes this is that's
what it was that's exactly what it's
like yeah it's like that i didn't think
you'd seen that not seen that oh like a
great series i love that show yeah
actually yeah but yeah that's
essentially what it's like they're not
like conservative
but because it's their parents they
don't like you it's kind of like ew
well nobody likes to think about their
parents
yeah
doing sexual [ __ ] so i can see i see
like if i had grown up and like my
parents were like into fetish kind of
stuff and we're going to fetish balls
all the time
and mradia says pro promiscuity is only
good on paper no dude no it's good i
mean it just depends on what it is
it depends on the situation it depends
on what the situation is yeah it depends
on what situation is
um
he says who is steve steve okay me and
grandpa's went to high school together
we were in the same drama program
okay
with mary lynn rice cub
who was she was on 24.
i dated mary lynn and [ __ ] steve did
he's trying to get me to talk about
maryland this is what i think he's
trying to but
marilyn was one of the scene and a bunch
of [ __ ] went down
and
just steve was
in the program and he got all the lead
roles
okay he could sing he looked good he
could [ __ ] dance he could he could
act too
i could act i could sing um later on i
ended up getting leads but that was in
uh brazil because i once i left that
school i went to another school in
brazil and went
i could have been gone to college like
marilyn did and [ __ ]
been all but man i'm so glad i didn't
i'm so glad that i did not become a
professional actor because to try to
[ __ ] live
in that world man would have driven me
[ __ ] crazy
the army was so much better
yeah they got money but you're in you're
out you gotta [ __ ]
those [ __ ] are
casting couch [ __ ] well that's
a lot of pressure yeah and then like
they're super super corrupt and just
like you don't want to it's a bad char
what's his name
look it's a bad seat what was the dude
from [ __ ] um from true romance uh
what's his name christian slater
christian slater somebody asked
christian slater he says who you you
don't date celebrities oh hell no
he's like and he's like what
where do you go because he just said i
don't hang out in hollywood he goes
that's a that's a bad scene that's a
terrible scene i just go there to
[ __ ] make movies
and everything i know about is a yeah
well the thing about it
when your whole industry yeah is based
around
pretending
um
you know i'm gonna say it's maybe not
the best place to like find a lifelong
partner because
you know slater only went out with
normal women
normal women with normal jobs
which is probably the best way to get
yeah honestly yeah that'll like at least
keep you grounded yeah
strong 78 says women should lower their
standards it's scientifically proven
yeah but we don't have to men need to
lower their standards too because
there's a lot of [ __ ] who are
threes who are [ __ ] chasing after
[ __ ] eights
i see that [ __ ] well like i said women
don't have to lower their standards we
don't have to why should we have to
there's a lot of dudes out there
that are they'll do it yeah that will do
it and even if they don't
i don't really give a [ __ ] right it's
like you know
what do i need that for it's just you
know i'm not having a baby
and
it's just more
aggro a lot of it's more stress that i
don't need so it's just kind of like i
don't need that a lot of the in my life
that i presented to you people
i i [ __ ]
i went over i went over it again it was
of breeding age
so a lot of the data is [ __ ] centered
around very young people on dating apps
okay and what their behaviors are and
young people are [ __ ] dumb
it's all well i was also dumb yeah we're
all dumb we were all done with that age
young people are [ __ ] dumb yeah they
are uh everybody is i was you were yeah
yeah
so
i'm just saying that when you get older
um it's a little more complicated and
the thing about it is that like i said
women don't
need you
um especially if they've already had a
kid or they don't want a kid
um they don't particularly need you for
anything
so you really have to
have something to offer
that's better than
them having control over their own lives
most women
most women
are happy with friendship stability and
[ __ ] dependability that's really
because you can have the biggest [ __ ] in
the world and be [ __ ] great and [ __ ]
like that but if she can't depend on
your ass can't trust you around money
what the [ __ ] good are you you're not
any good yeah like you're good for maybe
like
15 20 minutes yeah get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah
it's the same thing
exactly there's a lot of [ __ ] good
lines like i said big dick
right it's really not it doesn't mean
anything right because it's like unless
i can rely on you yeah when i'm in
trouble or unless like it doesn't really
it doesn't really mean anything in the
long run in the long run it's just like
in some of the [ __ ] movies looking
from white lightning and stuff like that
yeah like
some of those little southern movies
no you [ __ ] hot you don't marry hot
hot people [ __ ] crazy yeah hot young
people are [ __ ] crazy you don't want
that
well like i said it's just kind of it's
a different thing it's a different thing
um people that you just kind of like
[ __ ] for fun yeah and people that you
actually like rely upon is very
different there's very a little overlap
between those two things um you know
it's good if there's overlap but that's
not usually gonna happen not usually so
i kind of feel like most people are like
pretty old before they figure that out
you know
and they just keep trying to make it
work yeah you know what i mean it's like
yeah but she's so hot i'm like yeah but
she's stealing all your money or you
know or something it's it's just kind of
like always something like that
so
all right i'm gonna have one more drink
guys you want more yeah it's like it's
so early it's only 7 30. okay in about a
half hour we'll [ __ ] uh we'll give
you we'll give them another half hour
yeah
because we don't like i said we don't
have to leave until like nine no but we
got [ __ ] we got to do
that's true but at least i got my nails
done
i just gotta change my shirt put my
corset on put my shoes on
and then i'll be ready to go
hopefully i'm not gonna drink that much
of the bar i promise
uh camp guy says lots of deadbeats guys
will act like they have lots of money
girls don't find out until later that
the guy is deadbeat
yeah
i kind of feel like
this is something that i encounter a lot
writing about true crime
and we've like i said we've been
watching a lot of like uh unsolved
mysteries we're just like talking about
some old cases
very very common
and i was kind of thinking about one
that i was watching the other day
some dude that thank you
that
presents himself look i have a boat and
i have all this money and like and then
he sweeps her off her feet
i get like falling for that like i
probably wouldn't nowadays because i'm
old and like i've been through all of
that crap before
but i'm not gonna blame like a 20 30
year old woman for falling for that
because that's
what everybody wants right it's just
kind of like this dude and he
is secure and he has money and stuff
like that and he actually is like super
into you and
he's gonna give you all this stuff
but that's why you gotta like [ __ ]
watch man you gotta watch because
that usually ends up with like somebody
getting poisoned or somebody pushed off
a boat or something like that maybe i've
like watched as much as you cry
maybe but it does happen so you gotta
watch
you gotta watch for true crime
everybody's just a human
um
you know yeah it's awesome and it does
happen that like some dude is gonna
sweep you off your feet and he just
thinks you're the best [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
and he has money and he just wants to
give you everything that you ever wanted
it does happen but it's very very rare
and honestly if some dude is like giving
you that line you should be very very
suspicious very suspicious because that
dude's probably gonna like [ __ ]
poison you
he's probably gonna poison you at some
point
murder says i don't have any crushed
fruit i don't either um
to be honest i'm
i've never been a big fan
i've never been a big fan of children
and
this isn't really coming from a place
look i have three younger siblings who
are all
delightful and were actually delightful
when they were children also they were
actually fantastic when they were kids i
didn't mind them at all
um my parents when i was growing up uh
ran a daycare they ran a daycare center
and then later my mom ran a daycare in
our house so we always kind of had
little kids around the house when i was
growing up
um during that time period
i came to the realization
that i really
really
never wanted children
i told my mom this
i think when i was 15 or 16.
i was like you know mom i i really don't
think i want any kids
and she oh you'll change your mind
because my mom loves kids she had four
of her own
and she just she made a career of like
watching because she [ __ ] loves
children some women are built for it but
and to me i was just kind of like
okay maybe but it's like look i'm not
feeling it yeah
um the women that are feeling it usually
have kids but in their 20s
and it's like and i and i felt kind of
like look i love my mom and me and my
mom are a lot alike
but
i mean she [ __ ] loves children and i
was just kind of like i don't get it i
don't get it and it's just like the
whole time i was growing up i kind of
thought i was doing something wrong
because
my mom was like oh a little kid then i
was just kind of like gross i was just
like
i just wasn't like into it and it's like
every time like kids would kind of like
people bring their kids over and i'm
like can you
just keep them over there i'm just i'm
not really into it
but
she said i'd grow out of it but i never
did i never did i i never really bonded
to children i just
i don't know i i thought about it a
couple times but i was just like i don't
i don't know
it was just never something that so
every time somebody says oh women have
like a some kind of like genetic thing
it's like oh oh all they want children i
don't think that's the case because i
had never had that it's not genetic it's
hormonal i never had that the women that
are like that i always found children
like profoundly annoying and i've really
really really never wondered the women
that are like that [ __ ] are um have
hormones that kick in in their 20s
and um if they're not feeling it by
their 40s
they're not going to feel it
yeah and i mean
i'm willing to submit
that when i told her that when i was a
teenager that i was like look i don't
think i ever want children she's like oh
you'll change your mind later when you
like meet somebody or blah blah blah
um
that really never happened right to be
honest i got married when i was 22
i think i was 22 when i got married the
first time
and we talked about having a kid but
then like after that we're like well
that would really like kind of cramp our
style because we traveled a lot and we
did like a lot of other stuff and i was
like we just never got around to it
and then when i got older it's like
[ __ ] up
cheese from what i've observed
no thanks
the best moms are young and dumb you
want to get them in [ __ ]
20
18 19.
and then
they have the kid the kid grows up and
now they're young enough to actually
help the children you know
and there's and then once the child is
separated from them then the wife lives
their life or the wife the uh the mom
can't live her life yeah she's like well
now they're she's still young she's
doing home you know
right i don't know i was always focused
on other things i guess
when i was growing up i always wanted to
like
i was like man i want to like
write an amazing novel or i would i
wanted to do other things i i really
didn't really
i kind of felt like being
having a kid would just like saddle you
i kind of felt like i would be like
resentful about it
so
and honestly
this is kind of hilarious
but since we've got pookie
i'm kind of like oh my god i'm glad that
i never had a human child because i'm so
like worried about pookie all the time
like what is she doing is she okay blah
blah blah i was like oh my god if i had
a human kid i would be like absolutely
inseparable i'm really really good yeah
that's right
and that's a cat yeah so i'm just kind
of like yeah that's probably like the
best decision i've ever made okay we got
about uh
20 minutes if you guys want to [ __ ]
uh drop any super chats in we'll of
course accept those and uh if you guys
wanna
us to [ __ ] answer any questions in
terms of [ __ ] subjects
[ __ ] to be about this would be about
a good time because it might take us 20
minutes to answer
mr 88 says i grew up in socal and knew
and interacted with a lot of people that
were famous by the way pump up the
volume yeah starring christians that's a
great movie oh my god we should like
review that yeah that's a great [ __ ]
movie um was filmed at my high school
during my sophomore year
all right uh
greece was filled and filmed at my mom's
high school venice high at venice beach
that's where that was from yeah
mr 88 says i'm glad i never was dating
my wife and i married young both 20 and
have never had a fight in 25 plus
mystery i know you're very lucky yeah
i don't know like i kind of feel like
i don't know it
i don't want to say this across the
board
but probably you should fight because
if you don't fight that means that like
you agree on everything and that's
impossible yeah tammy says yeah i had
mine at 22 and 24 i'm now 53 it's my
time exactly exactly
and um
um
uh mr 88 yeah i was actually born um
right outside carson california
even though i was a child of the south
my dad was from the south so so was my
mom originally they just they just met
there my dad was in the navy
and they lived there for a while but
then i left in 81
i went to uh southern california
military academy
which is uh the military academy from
over the top that sylvester stallone
movie that's that's where i went
the one where they were like doing the
[ __ ] yeah
doing the arm wrestling right i'll show
you the arm wrestling yeah yeah yeah all
right yeah and then i laughed and
[ __ ] but oh my god i was more i you
know
every every [ __ ] uh summer i was
going to mississippi after my divorce
after the divorce
that my family my no [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] it up yeah
yeah you did
that's me right there
shaking the general's hands look at
little baby tom yeah let me see
yeah that was me as a second lieutenant
that's you all right yeah
that looks like some [ __ ]
facey maybe yeah
that was me in front of my [ __ ]
little platoon and [ __ ]
oh
little baby tom yeah
let's see if i can with your big ass hat
on a big ass hat
yeah
i [ __ ] loved that school though that
was a fun school
a lot of famous people came from that
school
that when i was a [ __ ] little
corporal
yeah look at my hair look at my hair
oh my god
that's the thing like you always like
structure i don't oh i love structure
structure and institution discipline i
don't yeah well
that's
look at me i mean that to me that feels
like very oppressive i'm like i love it
don't you [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me what
to do i love it i don't like being told
what to do
mr 88 says jen and i swapped maternal
instincts i'm a male and have degrees in
elementary and early childhood education
i've worked with little children my
whole life they're very interesting and
genuine they are and honestly
when i was younger
like
uh pre-teen
uh one thing that i actually really
enjoyed and i still remember it to this
day
is that when i was 12 or 13 we had a
program where we
would tutor
children in a
kindergarten first grade that were
a little bit behind like in reading and
stuff like that
and the kid that i tutored
was actually delightful he was a
delightful child
and um
to be honest like i heard that he
benefited a lot from me
because even back then i was kind of
like a dork like about
english and reading and all that kind of
stuff so
i got like really into all the kind of
like grammar and all that kind of stuff
and he like learned a lot from me and
apparently that was you know
that was something but i had a really
good time doing that
but
that said like i said because i was
around little kids all my life like like
i said
i'm the oldest of four children i had
three younger siblings like like i said
they are all delightful i love all my
siblings i have two brothers and one
sister and i love all of them
um and they were actually not annoying
in the least
and i hung out with them
live when i was older
uh but my parents ran a daycare so i ran
around i hung around with little kids
like pretty much my whole life
um
i didn't hate it but
it gave me a perspective
that maybe a lot of people don't have
so from a very early age i was just kind
of like yeah this is not
for me not for me
i i just really don't want to devote my
life
to this
um i don't want to feel responsible for
another person
um
yeah that's that's too much
so
so that was something
um
[Music]
tammy says there's a channel on youtube
called briefcase
a lot of young girls killed after they
tell their guy that they are pregnant
well uh
just from like writing about true crime
statistically
uh women who get pregnant and tell the
fathers of their children that they are
pregnant
uh they're statistically way more likely
to get murdered
than other women of uh comparable age so
there's that
so i'm i'm talking to [ __ ] brian
hackett
brian hackett went to the academy to me
oh with me
the one that i just showed you
and uh he works in hollywood he was in a
lot of movies he [ __ ] worked on bone
tomahawk with [ __ ] crustle
uh what was the one uh vfw vfw okay he
worked on a lot of good movies he worked
on a new gina carano flick that's coming
out [ __ ]
uh
terror on the prairie or horror on a
prairie that's coming out he worked on
that too
and uh yeah he's coming right now he
says he's coming in right now brian
hackett and we're going to talk about
over the top
he's coming in i haven't seen that in a
very long time i did see it but
uh but yeah mr 88 says
um
oh strong 78 says
my sister is the same always been
adamant about not having kids
i mean
i kind of came to that realization when
i was 16.
i was willing to
uh you know i was open to the
possibility you know maybe i'll get
older
and i'll change my mind
but
i really never did
i didn't think that i would but
everybody told me that i would so i was
like oh maybe i will we'll see how it
goes but i never did okay brian just
showed it showed up in the chat room
what's up brian brian
i was just talking about the academy i
showed some pictures all right where we
went to school
and then uh my friend
my friend connor watson from from mexico
uh says like man you could have been in
over the top
that's all about the movies that you
that you worked on you know
brian worked on [ __ ] vfw he worked on
bone tomahawk he worked on [ __ ]
terror in a prairie he's worked on a lot
of good movies hollywood all right
jenny walks up with her booty and [ __ ]
okay go ahead
and what i wanted to say
now that brian's here
and he can attest in the [ __ ] comment
section
the best thing about over the top
is that in that movie which it wasn't
actually [ __ ] filmed at the academy
but they used students from the academy
all right
the best thing about it is that
immortalized one of the greatest men
that i've one of the greatest man i've
ever known that was colonel sheahey
colonel sheahey was an old army colonel
from their artillery [ __ ] units who'd
been all over central and south america
and he mapped the whole [ __ ]
continent for the us army and he was one
of our teachers
and i just wanted to [ __ ] ask brian
if you remember how [ __ ] awesome
colonel shaheed was and colonel sheahey
was a mormon
a mormon
and uh his daughter [ __ ] uh went to
the [ __ ] uh ceremonies and [ __ ] all
the time
and uh he [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
funny
he'd been good he would say some [ __ ]
like you couldn't pull water out of a
boot if the instructions were on the
heel he would just say all kinds of [ __ ]
carl shay-hey was like the guy
from starship troopers remember that
[ __ ] scene where you were there in
school where where esteba what was his
name estevez i think is what his name
was he's in school and his badass high
school teacher
ends up showing up in
as an infantry officer
that's kind of the way colonel sheahey
was
i just wanted to see if [ __ ] brian
remembered him that [ __ ] was the
[ __ ]
yeah he goes i remember colonel shay hey
man he was awesome yeah he was he was
[ __ ] he was like uh
kind of like a a childhood idol for all
of us he was very much kind uh
what was that actor's name [ __ ]
ironside
uh richard ironside what was michael
michael ironside he was like our version
of michael ironside
in [ __ ] starship troopers
that's what he was like that dude was
right yeah you would have liked you
would like colonel shaheed he was cool
he was a testament to the mormon race
okay
i had a few mormons i mean yeah yeah
they're all right but i mean they have
some like weird-ass beliefs but okay
yeah yeah
a lot of people have weird-ass beliefs a
lot of people have weirdos yeah yeah
we've got the restroom back a second
it's all right
yeah i'm gonna come back hey brian i'm
gonna ask you some questions when i come
back i'm gonna ask you about about the
movies hold on
tammy says
my daughter always said she didn't want
to have kids she's almost 30 and still
has no desire
yeah
i kind of feel like that might be
something that manifests early
as i said when i was a teenager
um
i told my mom's like look i i really
don't think that i'm ever
really gonna wanna have kids it's just
it's not for me
it's it's just not my thing and she was
like oh well you change your mind like
when you meet somebody special or
whatever
and when i was in my early 20s i did and
i got married i was married for 15 years
and the whole time that we were married
we were kind of like yeah maybe we'll
have a kid and then we're like yeah no
let's not
let's not
uh we just never got around to it uh we
were doing other things we were
interested in other things like i said
we like to travel we like to do other
things so it's just kind of like we just
never got around to it
then in 2010 2011 whatever it was we got
divorced
and
i don't know by that time i was like in
my late 30s and i was like well
even if i wanted a kid it's kind of too
late now
um and i thought about it for a second
and then i was just kind of like
no no
so i do kind of feel like there's a
whole there's
you have to really really want the [ __ ]
you have to really want the [ __ ]
because it's
it consumes your whole entire life and
you really have to and i'm
i don't know i'm just i think i
very early on like twigged on to that
fact and i was like i don't really know
if i can do that i don't really know if
i can
give my whole entire
uh
identity like to another person
you know if it had happened i would have
done it but
it never did and i just never got around
to i just never got a hard tip
okay i gotta check i gotta check
messages there's certain things i guess
he can't say hold on
okay i'm checking i'm checking brian
tammy says uh i remember
oh wait she does have two gorgeous cats
that she calls my grandkids yeah i mean
honestly
okay
i i actually kind of
think of pookie as my
child yeah
we treat her like a human child
she acts like a human child to be honest
brian is asking if there's any way he
can come on the show live right now
no there's no way we don't have it set
up
um
we could possibly uh get the uh the
software that we need to have somebody
call in and put them on the show live
that would be fun jenny is there any way
we can look into that uh yeah we could
probably go okay speaking of pookie yeah
they're spooky there's pokey we don't
have the software we don't have the
software right now brian
but um
how's um
tara on the prairie coming um when's
that gonna be out
and are you gonna give me the code so i
can watch that [ __ ] free oh no i know
what it was oh
no no i'll get you trying to get it no
no no no no last last time i saw the
free movie is uh
he should yeah there's a uh a premiere
on youtube you can see it free and then
after that you got a picture well that's
what we did with the last
movie right
now brian brian and i'm willing to pay i
don't really like to like watch it for
free if i'm they're gonna put that [ __ ]
behind a paywall which brian and i don't
really agree with that that needs to be
up there so everyone can [ __ ] just
see it and order it all a la carte it
really is with it just the way netflix
does it they're not netflix uh
well if you put it up there for like 399
or 399 or something people will buy it
right yeah yeah i kind of feel like
maybe you should do that because
look if
if i can pay to watch something
or if i can watch something for free but
with ads yeah then i will do that
because that's maybe giving like some
money back to the creator hopefully yeah
i don't want to watch it for free
if especially if it's like an indie
movie yeah i don't really like to do
that because
yeah brian if i put you on my ear on
[ __ ] live chat there's a delay and
the delay will [ __ ] everything it's a
five second there's like a fight and
we'll [ __ ] everything up it's so much
better
to uh bring you on so you can uh comment
live on our stream that that would be a
lot better but we don't have a software
set up for that yet
uh he said no info on terror yet i heard
june release but they haven't told me
anything okay all right
and he's going okay now bro
um
what's up puke camp guys yeah looking
forward to seeing that movie though i
think it's gonna yeah i mean it looked
good
and they had gina up there and gina was
looking [ __ ] dirty and filthy like
she'd been at least in the photos that i
saw
she looked [ __ ] rough as hell which
makes me think that that's gonna look
like a really cool [ __ ]
western
really cool western movie
because people weren't clean
you know
not like nowadays yeah not like that
that's what she's doing people work
camp guy says great tammy my wife and i
really got into it when we had kids so
it was a good experience yeah and i'm
glad like like i said i'm glad that some
people have that but
i was never willing to
i was like look if i had a kid
then that would be like
my life would be ruined essentially yeah
um i wasn't really willing to
go that extra step
yeah yeah i don't think it was that much
into it straw dog says that [ __ ] bone
tomahawk was a blast of a movie and
[ __ ] brian came in because it was a
blast to work on uh yeah but i mean
boom tomahawk was so good i was so good
i was up here talking
[ __ ] about how good
those movies were phone tomahawk and
[ __ ] vfw before i even knew brian
worked on him
me and brian just made contact after
that he had heard about me through the
show
and he's oh i know this dude [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's it's uh it was
just it's that's the that's the miracle
of the internet
i didn't know that he worked on those
but uh no you guys need to see vfw too
and bone tomahawk those are really good
movies brian worked on them both
what was that new one that we saw that
uh just went on [ __ ] uh it's behind
the paywall now
um that one was pretty good with the
drug addicted woman locked yeah yeah um
what was the name of that [ __ ] thing
it was pretty good he did the sound that
was all right yeah yeah it was pretty
good i just i'm just kind of upset that
it's behind a paywall
it just needs to be on a site where you
can buy it all the cars i mean we got to
see it because we saw the premiere but
yeah they saw the premiere like i said
that's the cool thing about the internet
nowadays and this has happened to me a
lot um because i review a lot of horror
books shut in he says there you go shut
it shut it shut in is good that was
actually a good movie yeah good movie i
liked it a lot
yeah brian go ahead go ahead and tell me
what the rest of the movies are and i'll
plug them because he worked on a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of them
but interestingly
because i review horror books yeah
um
one i get a lot of people like sending
me their books to review which i will
because somebody sent me one today and
i'm gonna read that and review it next
month
but
interestingly when i put up a video
of
like reviewing an indie book and i do a
lot of those sometimes i'll get like
some
kind of like appreciation from the
authors which is like awesome because
i'm also a horror writer so it's cool to
like
get
i mean very famously i reviewed
uh a book called the nightmare room by
chris sorensen
um and i loved it i thought it was like
fantastic okay and what brian worked on
dragon dragged across concrete yeah i
still i still need to see that puppet
master
the littlest reich satanic pen yeah i
haven't seen i haven't seen that well
there have been a lot of um
yeah there have been a lot of uh and
then vfw
terror on the prairie
bone tomahawk
you worked on good movies [ __ ] you
brian
yeah
hack it you worked on some good movies
probably works on some [ __ ] movies too
though but [ __ ] brian send me some
pictures of him in crustal
whenever like i said it's a job like any
other job right him across you how to
[ __ ] do escape from l.a
wasn't that also uh that crusoe movie
where they were out in the desert
[ __ ] uh where the uh
breakdown
didn't you have something to do with
that
i thought one of those pictures was from
breakdown i mean that was a while back
though i thought i saw a picture of him
and crosstalk in the desert that he sent
me
i couldn't understand that remember
jenny and i were talking about the
crustal sphere the crustal sphere
embraced me
only two degrees away from kurt russell
i'm doing the show next thing you know
crustal sphere came and goes yeah man
dude that dude you grew up with [ __ ]
nose cross will work with russell
it happened without
can't plan that [ __ ]
clan plan it can't plan it's the force
it's six degrees it goes
it's six degrees of kevin
we love him uh the seventh day with guy
pierce he worked for that the last
minute that was the last movie worked on
before the pandemic kid
okay he just said
brian said he just visited the set of
escape from l.a okay okay okay
that was kind of a terrible
yeah it wasn't uh it it was a little too
goofy
but over time i've i've kind of loosened
up to it yeah it's like
it's i wish it would have been played
straight kind of like the first one
had they played it straight
i'd liked it a lot better
it's more like a what do you call it
like a satire
yeah i mean you know
uh i there was something i wanted to
like
yeah brian says tell jenny now i listen
to all your podcasts oh that's good
that's good
tammy says my mom had seven kids
and i'm the only one that has any
contact with her and it's like oh my god
brian said he's gonna send me a picture
with crustal the night he visited okay
all right
when you send it send it and i'll show
it on the show i'll show it on the
screen
camp guy says i once knew a kid that
wanted to become a hollywood makeup
artist
age 12 he had a full fishing tackle box
full of makeup and stuff
please tell me that he went to like i
don't know like the tom savini school or
something like that
there is a makeup school in orlando
i mean tom savini has a couple of like
uh
makeup schools
around the country
so
when i was younger i kind of wanted to
do that i kind of wanted to
be like a
somebody that made like monsters for
movies i was like because you know even
when i was a kid i was all into like
horror [ __ ] and i was just kind of like
man
how awesome would that be like your
whole career was just like making
monsters and like doing like makeup on
people like i was really into that so i
thought about doing that
but
it never happened unfortunately he said
he's looking for that picture i said
okay
yeah it's eight o'clock it's almost time
to [ __ ] shut it down
is it i'm still having a good time
though yeah you have to get ready
we're leaving around now honestly all i
have to do yeah is put my shoes on okay
put the corset on and put a different
shirt on all right
that's literally all i have to do okay
and maybe like powder my nose and chicks
i'm probably shiny
but
you know
just saying
we don't have like that much to do
yeah in case you just came we're going
out after so
we're we're doing all that
mango just got here
jesus wants to show up now all right
dude man you're late as [ __ ]
tom's already like talking about like
maybe we should shut the [ __ ] down and i
was just kind of like
well it's about that time
well don't be that way we still have a
while we still want no
no we don't have a well
we have 20 minutes
yeah that's not a while that's quick
yeah we have 20.
we have 20 minutes
okay
rebecca says the guy that won an oscar
best makeup for for braveheart was a
makeup academy
here
uh at the gold coast is making [ __ ]
12 thousand dollars a pop
mr ad says shortcuts best movie with the
[ __ ] horror makeup subplot
bunny did it mr muffin came for some
tubby rubs whatever that is
who's mr muffin that must be the cat
mangoes just got back from seeing the
nic cage
nick cage movie it's great amazing go
see it
nick cage
or nick cave nick cage yeah i wish in a
cave yeah look has anybody came in the
north man
that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] uh that that video game
isn't it
i don't know mortal kombat
what are you talking that was luke cage
that's that was okay i don't know
nick cages
okay
he sent me the crusoe picture
okay all right i'm just saying that all
right
i was asking everybody if they had seen
the north man yet should i go see it
tomorrow
hey brian will crystal
get crushed on look at crap yeah it's
back in the day
what's this mullet yeah
i don't know who that is who's that
i can't really tell it's very blurry
mango says i'm off to see the northbound
on monday
i mean it sounds awesome
oh that's that's uh what's his name
um
wasn't that uh
the director
guy that directed [ __ ] um
the thing
and every and all the other movies
and all the other movies the thing and
the director of the thing the [ __ ]
um well the thing was john carpenter
john carpenter that was john carpenter
that doesn't look like i think it was
john carpenter that doesn't look like
john carpenter that's john carpenter is
it that's john carpenter
oh yeah i guess that's john carpenter oh
okay yeah
yeah yeah that's right
it didn't look like him yeah it's john
carpenter
uh rebecca says north man isn't out here
until thursday next week i'll see it i
mean everybody that i've heard that's
seen it so far because apparently it
opened in some locations
this weekend
everybody's into it they're like oh yeah
that's metal as [ __ ]
yeah brian i said that's john carpenter
yeah it's john carpenter of course i
didn't recognize him yeah he's just not
as skinny as you remember him
i think that's why like you look kind of
like fat
not fat but
bigger than usual
uh startup 78 says the world needs
another badass werewolf movie with all
practical effects transformation scene
yeah that'd be awesome but you know
um
yeah
robert eggers that's what i'm saying
it's like i
really want to see it i'm still pissed
that i missed x in the theaters
i was gonna go see it last weekend
uh you know the
ty west movie
and it wasn't playing anymore where i am
so i didn't get to
so you know
he was freezing that night okay
been out in the uk for just over a week
i think that the north man started
just
thursday evening i think i'm not really
entirely sure but i know everybody's
been like looking forward to because
like robert eggers you know what i mean
the witch the lighthouse
we're all into that so you know
uh so you know i'm maybe i'll go see you
tomorrow we'll see
we'll see how i feel
after we go out this evening
uh
yeah that's why you look fatter yeah
it's like it's weird because
yeah i didn't recognize him immediately
anyone know where you can stream x in
the uk i'm not really sure
i think here you can stream it on amazon
but it's like 20 bucks
but you have to wait for like a few
weeks and that'll be cheap i wanted to
see it in the theater
as i said and i wanted to go last
saturday to see in the theater but it
wasn't playing anymore so yeah
brian said that [ __ ] carpenter was
all [ __ ] bulked up in three jackets
that's why he looked [ __ ] fatter
yeah because that [ __ ] is skinny every
time i see carpenter [ __ ] looks
skinny as [ __ ]
he's dead now right yeah i think he's
dead i think he's the dead he died me i
think he died no no no
he's not dead he did that he did that he
did that last halloween
well yeah that's right he's alive i
think you got to be anxious though by
now well yeah but yeah i think he's
alive
i mean i know wes craven died right and
then
i don't know they're all dying brian's
asking you something
off topic jenny every time i listen to
one of you guys podcasts on a particular
film i end up watching that film
the same day yeah but that's good yeah
well that's why we do them and honestly
we just picture we don't even have like
any
criteria uh we just pick [ __ ] like
whatever it is this is our criteria
whatever we're in the mood for that day
and to be honest with you
look i have my own
uh show that i do
where i review i do a couple shows a
week i usually do one new one and one
old one
but when we're doing like movie
retrospective or the matinee or
something like that i try to pick stuff
that i think that tom is going to like
which is a much narrower yes yes thing
no i'm just saying that's much narrower
than what i would
pick because honestly like i like a lot
of different things but you usually like
one specific type of thing
so
i usually try to pick something that i
think that you would like
well brian says we all have the same
taste
yeah yeah
i mean i like a lot of different things
yeah um
i like a lot of good [ __ ] too though it
just has to be good
but i don't like [ __ ] that's too [ __ ]
drawn out
she knows what i don't like
that's what i mean but see the thing
about it is that
rebecca says please review night hunter
it's got an all-around amazing cast
that's brilliant never heard of it oh
you know that's actually you know that
one
yeah yeah i've never heard it that's a
good city yesterday
the one that i'm putting up tomorrow
is an australian flick called wake in
freight have you guys seen that one
donald pleasance is in it
uh it came out in 1971 it's a
psychological
thriller
and
it's a very interesting film it's very
interesting film
not horror necessarily but
i don't know it has a lot of like
horrific elements like i said i'm
willing to watch like a lot of different
things because i'm just kind of
just show me what you're doing brian
says the new chinese horror the sadness
is amazing
oh i've heard a lot of good [ __ ] about
that i've seen a lot of um one of my
favorite horror channels
they did a
video about that i didn't watch it
because i said well i'm probably gonna
watch that movie but they were just kind
of like yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ] me up and
i was just going like really oh bundy
recommended is it like super gory i'm
into it i'm not into it bundy recommends
dust boat i've seen it it was good i've
seen it submarine movie i've seen it too
yeah it's good i watched it in school
actually long time ago they showed it to
us in school
yeah mango says wick and freight is a
great film it is
and i kind of feel like
if you guys are into australian new wave
or osploitation
uh mad max anything like that
you should definitely watch wake and
freight it um
it was kind of lost for a long time they
lost the negative and blah blah but they
found it later and
it's not a horror film
necessarily it's more like psychological
but
you know there's brian with peter
billingsley
i'm not sure who peter billingsley is
but he wanted me to show that was he was
the one that was in um
you're gonna shoot your eye out is that
what it is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] creator story yeah the christmas
story that's right yesterday yeah
that's right
i recognize you now yeah yeah yeah
i'm glad that at least mango like knows
wicked freight honestly i i think
i saw wick and freight mentioned
and i think i said this in my review
which is going out tomorrow
there was a
a documentary
it was on shutter i don't know if it's
on there anymore but it was called
not quite hollywood and it was about
australian cinema back in the 70s so it
was like mad max all that kind of la and
the stuff that came out around it
so it was all about the australian
indie
film industry
and i think that i heard about wake and
fright
for the first time
when i saw that documentary so it got me
interested in like watching it
and then i noticed that it was on to be
for free and i was just kind of like man
i really need to get around to that and
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] it reminded
me of and this is maybe like a super
obscure
uh
reference
but
back in the old days
i used to have this book
you remember back in the day
that alfred hitchcock
had these
horror story anthology books
and he would put i don't know if he read
the [ __ ] or not but he would like put
his name on it
one of my favorite ones was called
stories that scared even me my
grandfather gave it to me
when i was very little
and a lot of the stories in that are
still some of my favorite short stories
of all time good hit like button people
thank you thumbs up
yeah
let's move it up one of the stories in
stories that scared even me was called
tough town
and it was by
what was his name
henry
sleazar sleazar something like that
so he wrote this story about like the
salesman that like turn up this town
everybody's like acting really weird
toward him and like some
[ __ ] ensued
this movie
reminded me of that story in the best
possible way
go into this movie it's on to be for
free you can watch it it's called wick
and freight it's australian it's not a
horror movie
but
it's like a psychological
i don't know i don't know what's the
best way to describe it it's kind of
like straw dogs
you've seen straw dogs sam pack and paw
it's kind of like that if you like that
then you'll probably like this but like
with a more australian twist to it also
donald pleasance is in it and he's
amazing
so
yeah you'll see my review tomorrow
unless you're on patreon and in which
case you'll see have seen it today but
you know what i
mean
peter billingsley worked in hollywood
his whole life not sure what he did yeah
each camp guy said that yeah yeah
and everybody is sad because everybody
knows him from a christmas story yeah
as the like a little kid yeah but that
was an iconic role
it was yeah john gore says i got to see
polanski movie called pleasants
called made with pleasants and then
donald please they call it
i think
yeah you know what i don't think i've
seen another movie you gotta see if you
if you like polanski you want to see uh
the tenant
that's a [ __ ] weird ass i mean
polanski as like as [ __ ] up busy as a
person he made like some [ __ ] amazing
movies yeah
tenant knife in the water like he made
like all kind of good [ __ ] bryce mary's
baby yeah
he was good
he know what he's doing yeah
that's what kind of got my mind got a
well with an underage girl but it's kind
of like
we're all kind of doing that [ __ ]
um that's why i'm not like look i'm not
getting down with it but [ __ ]
that [ __ ] there
he ran you know had he done his [ __ ]
time thank you mango thank you what a
mega had that [ __ ] done his time he'd
have been out by now
and he'd be out probably making movies
again
uh but he ran that's why a lot of people
hating on him
shouldn't run
well if he'd owned up to it i kind of
feel like a lot of people would have
forgiven him right thank you mango what
do you say i'm drunk as a skunk yeah me
too yeah
been out with my mosh bro to see the
unbearable weight of massive talent
movie of the decade or century
cage is the man yeah that's the movie
about nicholas cage okay
the embarrassment
the [ __ ] out the talent cage in the [ __ ]
up maybe hack it could hook me up with
cage which we gotta [ __ ] hack it we
gotta go [ __ ] find cage well they're
making fun of that [ __ ] drink with
that [ __ ]
they're making fun of the whole movie
like the oh the umber what is it called
the unbearable weight of what was that
movie called it was a book before the
unbearable weight of like [ __ ]
something being or something like that
i'd have to talk with cage i'd have to
have a serious talk with him he seems
rad
if you like i said any actor
have you seen vampires kiss no you have
not
yeah i think i've seen that one i think
i've seen that one now any actor that's
willing to one eat a cockroach and two
just
i don't even care like
i'm just gonna go like [ __ ] whole hog
with the [ __ ] i'm taking it completely
seriously and i'm just gonna like go all
in with it
i'm sorry you have my respect you have
my respect brian i'll tell you this
brian
i respect cage because no matter what
kind of piece of [ __ ] movie he's in he
does not phone that [ __ ] in he gives it
100
he he will [ __ ]
he will go all out
on a piece of [ __ ] movie he will change
the [ __ ] out
and why do you think everybody why do
you think he's so beloved so i'm like
yeah all right
why do you think he said we'll love it
do your [ __ ] cage
yeah yeah do it do your [ __ ] like i said
he has fans of his own yeah
they're not they're not
they're almost kind of like the inverse
of a [ __ ] of a [ __ ] uh
[ __ ]
steven seagal fan steven seagal fan
[ __ ]
we'll kind of [ __ ] watch his [ __ ]
he's the shittiest thing in the movie
but but for some reason they watch it
anyway
a cage fan will watch nicolas cage
movies he's the best part of the movie
they'll watch a piece of [ __ ] yeah
always because he's in it yep
because he's in it i'm among that like
look if nicholas cage is in it i will
watch it you'll watch it i don't give a
[ __ ] what it's about right
for that reason yeah and you don't know
what he's gonna do right you don't know
anything about it cage he's not
dependent on stunt doubles to walk up
and down stairs
like [ __ ] seagal is
look people i gotta [ __ ] announce
something
i gotta go back and [ __ ] look at my
search history and [ __ ] get i don't
remember the exact details
steven seagal is making a [ __ ]
youtube [ __ ] of movies no he's not yeah
he is he's doing youtube [ __ ] in russia
doing martial arts and
people are [ __ ] confirmed with him
about martial arts and they'll sit down
on a big old [ __ ] table and he's
sitting there stuffing himself and then
he'll go about a whole he'll talk like
look i'm not even gonna show up unless
you guys have freedom yes and he'll be
dressed up he's dressed up as as a as a
[ __ ] as dressed up as a [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] kung fu come on deflecting
people and [ __ ]
and i i saw it and i was just [ __ ]
laughing i go i gotta go back and study
this [ __ ] i mean you gotta appreciate
the grip
it is a grift and it was only a couple
weeks old and he's in russia
[ __ ] making these [ __ ]
youtube he's got a youtube channel
or somebody had him on his youtube their
youtube channel but i got to go back and
see it i couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it
i was like okay do you have a gun
to watch that no
seagal has discovered youtube
i will watch videos of people like
making fun of it like [ __ ] case cinema
because shitkay cinema
he doesn't like all of his videos aren't
about cigar movies but he has done like
a lot of videos about if seagal was
[ __ ] smart he'd tear the [ __ ] up uh
he would tear
youtube you would think that he would
like oh i'd be [ __ ] playing that [ __ ]
i'd be leaning
like lean into it yeah it looked like he
was kind of doing it
but it wasn't his channel i don't think
it was on another dude's channel well
i would lean the kids
problem i would have a steven seagal
channel his problem yeah is that he
takes himself completely seriously yeah
which
i mean to the rest of us
is funnier
but
i mean for his bottom line probably not
like the angle that you want to go at it
from
yeah uh cage was so good in pig he was
actually i
i mean pig was so
good
we we reviewed that yeah
that was a good that was a good
anti-action movie it was so good it was
the anti-action one nicholas cage like i
said people to think that he can't act
no [ __ ]
[ __ ] he'll chew the [ __ ] scenery
he would no he was amazing at that
amazing act he'd do whatever he can and
he wasn't chewing scenery no he didn't
have he was understanding there was all
kind of like layers and [ __ ] like that
it was like it was amazing that wasn't
like amazing
yeah yeah he's good he can do it does he
have a oscar
does he it's time for [ __ ] nicholas
cage to get an oscar you should probably
get an honorary before like for real
i've been a fan
and i'm not just saying this i've been a
fan of nicholas cage since
valley girl yeah valley girl when did
that come out 81 82.
yeah man he was fantastic in that
and he was in the [ __ ] david lynch
movie wild at heart and he was like oh
my god he was like so [ __ ] good at
that this is like a [ __ ]
the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] that he did with
his jacket and it's like oh my god he
was so good and brian said tom my friend
was boom operator on willy's wonderland
that was a great movie
yeah
he didn't say a word to the whole
[ __ ] movie and he got the girl and
ran off in the [ __ ] car at the end it
was great it was a great movie
willie's wondering it was no joke like i
said
this is why i like nicolas cage because
he's just kind of like what oh you're
offering me a role where i never talk
right okay
okay jen and he did it it's 18 30 it's
time to shut this [ __ ] down we gotta get
ready sure yep 83 for a valley girl okay
so yeah
we should review valley girl at some
point we can do it we can get around to
it
have you ever seen it uh yeah a long
time ago i forgot man got like some
modern english got some psychedelic fur
in there i remember
it's good it's a good movie
nick cage was great and on frozen ground
i don't think i've seen that one
uh yes he has an oscar
while at heart grave movie it was
okay
tom's getting pissed off yeah they're
pissed off we gotta go so we have to go
so yeah we're gonna leave in like half
an hour so we have to yeah i gotta
finish getting ready you guys start
getting ready we will see you guys later
we gotta [ __ ] go to the club tonight
it is friday go out and have [ __ ] fun
because it i'm
not totally loaded but by the time we
actually leave i'll [ __ ] be slightly
ugly i'll be recovered yeah but uh we'll
see you guys uh sunday sunday okay we'll
see you sunday we'll talk about a movie
yeah on sunday say brian i'll drop you a
message next time we [ __ ] do a show
with you
you know if you're around then you can
join in yeah well i'll look into i'll
look into uh the software we need to get
somebody to be able to call in
probably be through something like
[ __ ] skype or something we'll see
what they have here
we'll see yeah we'll figure it out
there's something on this program that
probably allows for it oh yeah okay i'm
using obs so i'll see what it is
uh but yeah so we will see you guys
sunday we'll talk about a movie or
whatever it is uh we're gonna go out you
guys have a good friday night and
saturday uh and we'll see you guys
saturday afternoon we will see you later
bye